I'm going live
what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation
Greg's gonna learn how to be on this
side today well John are we we're live
right conceptually I think we're live
let us know people I think we're live
how do you guys like koi Doc it's haunt
me for the rest of my day I think that
greatly is the the new terms Scott Welsh
described it as as comic observant
Fielder designed only for knowledge and
I was like I think it's brilliant I love
it koi Doc's good work my mom's in the
chat she she caused Kodak to exist drink
your Chief everyone drink your G fuels
this episode brought to you by delicious
G fuel which I requested at the door
today powered by g-fuel today people all
right select tubs with code reject
Nation all one word all right I just
feel being in the center John I don't
like it
I've lost my purpose and now all I and
now I'm just here with free hands and I
don't know what to do with my hands and
your center of attention today I said
don't want to be that better of
attention you're the only one of us who
had time to watch it three times so
you're gonna nail this you're gonna
you're gonna lay down sure the opinions
today yeah absolutely he's the shortest
of us I'm here to throw a wrench in
everyone's gears today we are a positive
force and he's the most positive so he's
the sitter because he's got a Sean says
it takes three times the chance
as to how and why my third viewing was
the way it was but I broke it down John
but I will say this actually I don't
know I'll talk about it if anybody cares
when we're going to talk about it oh
we're going to go into it so guys in the
chat you know what what everyone in the
chat thank you for everyone who's here
by the way if you're here please go
ahead leave a like be very much
appreciated helps with the playback on
this video but we are going to keep this
one focused today what is everyone's
like General opinion right now Rotten
Tomatoes critics love it audiences hate
it and then uh the cinema score is
through the roof right now these are all
accurate facts that you can check up
online trust me you don't want to doubt
me on that but it is no I don't know
what's real one through ten should we
say like everybody give a number I'd
love to I'd love to see people six
you're a six I'm a six I'm a
6.4 way to be generous that's nice John
did you Skyrocket I'm like seven and a
half congratulations man all right all
right I I this is the first time I would
ever encourage somebody not to go to
IMAX and instead go to 3D 3D was much
better I'm Max I think really exposes
the artifice of this movie in a way that
does not help where 3D actually helps it
feel like you went to a real place that
wasn't just a green screen much trippier
in 3D like it's much more immersively
disorienting in a good way and 40 I mean
I started 40x so I would say go for that
because when you're getting thrown
around that's the most immersive when it
feels like a Universal Studio the best
way to love this movie is it's not watch
it it's easier don't watch it at home
don't watch it on the biggest screen go
to three make sure you watch it on 3D
then you'll see it's an Orford great
movie right there don't watch but IMax
IMax doesn't help it because all the
extra resolution exposes the artifice
whereas all the filtration of 3D helps
it to facilitowing 7.5
I'm just saying that I was able to while
there are flaws with the movie certainly
still I was able to enjoy the experience
front to back and that's the thing I
wanted most each time I saw it so
selling it on Thursday night with like a
a good audience who is who did not clap
at the end you know who had gripes but
who was into it and it was a better
format it was a much more enjoyable time
at the MCU at the movie well looking at
the chat I'm glad John your opinion went
up
um as always now what I'm looking for
here in this chat I'm seeing everything
going from like six to seven primarily
actually I mean I'm actually I'm
downplaying it it's more like between
six to eight is where everyone's really
hovering with this film
um I'm not seeing too much in this in
the chat right now like super
enthusiastic comments and uh we got a
several super chats that we do get to
and thank you to guys who are doing
Super Chat streamlabs of course also
appreciate it they take less fees
YouTube takes like a giant cut so much
there's like no we we deserve like 50 of
it we pretty much assume you're here
because of us the actual structure not
not your content yeah the YouTube name
okay I've seen some nine out of tens
here however
um what was I talking about prior uh
score experience watch I think they were
caught up score experience 3D I'm how to
watch it so it's disappointed in the
right way I think my issue the second
time I've only seen it twice the first
time in 2D the second time in 3D I did
prefer the 3D which is not something I
often say is that I liked the first two
acts even more the second time and was
almost to the point where I was like
judging myself for not liking the movie
and then at the exact same moment the
first time something happens and I go oh
no it's worse because I had been happier
so like the higher dropping lower was
more jarring so I fell further into the
pit of despair so uh I I honestly it
went from like a c
minus to like a c yeah it's like a c
minus still but it just feels more
painful I wanted to love this uh yeah
what it reached for me the second time
around two was the first half of them
like when I said in our non-spoiler
review the 30 minute chunk that I really
like is when you go to the king
flashbacks with him and Janet and then
you know Kang meeting Ant-Man to me
still the best scene in the whole movie
and then they have the probability realm
I thought that was a great sequence
so that 30 minute chunk I think is
really solid yeah uh the but then you
know in the second time around like
actually you know what this even the
first part it's not too bad I'm not like
massively emotionally invested but it's
fun
I would check out once in a while going
but I know a lot of this is not going to
pay off it's an issue is like the movie
for me is okay so I'm just gonna dive in
and hopefully that's okay with everyone
here the announcement of Kang in an
Ant-Man movie which apparently was
playing since soon after the second
movie so it wasn't just like we need
Kang I looked into this they like wanted
Kang in Ant-Man for a long time so I was
thinking and this is spoilers everyone
I'm gonna say some spoiler spoilers are
coming no more warning spoilers spoilers
spoilers they literally already been
spoiling but I'm going going hard they
literally put Kang in the only movie
where there's an Avenger that deals with
time in a non-time traveling way
Ant-Man deals with relativity of time
when he's big and when he's small time
is relative to Ant-Man why to the
audience why
did they not have an element of
lost time being a factor therefore
having Kang offer Scott as he has
alluded to in the trailer time with his
daughter why did they not threaten Scott
by aging up Cassie instead of using
telekinesis like age up and like
sacrifice more time with her or offer
him time again time right there three
they didn't make like it's right there
and then the relativity thing if you've
got wasp Ant-Man and Cassie their sense
of time is relative in the quantum realm
why not have something involving like a
Time Vortex instead of a force field
with minions something where only
Ant-Man could be the one who could get
through if he can kill Thor if he can
kill all these other Avengers something
has to be unique to Ant-Man to make the
story work and he's the only Avenger
with time relativity and they didn't
even touch on that they also put Ant-Man
and Cassie in the quantum realm which is
microscopically small and then plate
broke their own rules wherein they got
bigger and needed Citrus and all those
fun jokes of like when he's bigger
they're still microscopic the bigger of
small is still very small the they broke
their own rules they they don't have the
fundamentals of what time relativity
even means down there because you also
don't see a single moment where like
when they hug their relative to a place
we've never been so you don't care
you're not invested they're just hugging
like they're just and they're on a
platform with buildings in the
background that don't look as scopic as
they could it was again I got the sense
of scope better in 3D but it is like a
bit of a strange stage and one line a
single line one line of dialogue fixes
my Kang problem one one one one one at
the end of the movie spoilers again I
know I'm just nervous I'm not used to
saying spoilers they are a council of
Kings talk about Kang you know what one
of them could have said a council one of
the kangsul could have literally just
said and so we uh you know banished our
weakest member but even our weakest
being thwarted by an Avenger is shameful
they could have literally acknowledged
that was weak Kang and then it'd be like
oh now I'm worried for phase five but
instead we've got this situation where
it's like now we've had two properties
be like guys guys guys guys guys Kang's
gonna get worse and no he's you can't
keep easing at some point you got to
give me like I'm done with appetizers
give me the meal we've been appetized
all right that's a great koi Ranch there
a crant that's a good crant right there
I want to love them I do love Jonathan
Majors Jonathan Majors was Kang but the
writing wasn't cool the plot wasn't
sorry sorry it's funny as I I thought
koi would really love this movie and you
were right with him oh like every
conversation Greg and I had for a week
was like you know I didn't like it but I
don't want to say too much I don't want
I was like don't tell me too much yeah
and then like then I walked and then
there's my next so we all saw it
together and at one point I saw John
change his body language so I was like
oh no this was gonna start to get like
worse and then I saw Greg look over at
me and I felt my own face being like
and I was like oh no and then it's just
a second what moment was that uh it was
as soon as the ants were announced I
knew that would be the third act as soon
as Michael Douglas goes there's a
technological city of ants and that's
another thing okay so oh whoa whoa koi
we got we gotta reserve some of this
because you never know okay
you know the same way I've got a better
way Hank Pym walks through this movie
going I like ants you should walk
through this stream going I like rants I
do like Rants and I wouldn't Michael
Douglas needs to be my my deep fake all
right I have a better ending for Michael
Douglas teach me the ways did I do this
for the see the super chats oh my God so
if I wanted more Godwin Alex watch
another stream people saying I'm too
much this is what I do on this channel
I'm enjoying things uh over animated
[__] yourself uh no like I'm gonna do
what I want you're here [__] off or not
that was a nice blast of energy just
there yeah that's what I was like what
are you trying to get us demonetized koi
I'm trying to get the people that want
to talk crap not in here koi myself I
spent too much time on Twitter so I said
oh dude I see going out to her I'm like
this can't be good for the brain I do it
between sets it helps my workouts I'm
like it's like games because I get angry
and then I get stronger all right guys
I'm gonna dive into here Dan v900
love and thunder was awful it had the
higher Cinema score than uh Ant-Man and
the WASP what is B plus it's B plus and
Ant-Man in the West condominious B black
panther 2 had a rough first 90 minutes
with an Avengers finale and I hated the
last 10 minutes of quantumania Kang was
completely undercut well we did a video
about the mid credits scene we expressed
our thoughts on it how I thought it felt
like a cartoon and is not threatening
and someone brought a point that was
brought up to me from Omni media Michael
B
um he said he realized when the movie
was done that it doesn't change it's a
movie that's all about setting up phase
five but it literally tells you nothing
new nothing there's no there's nothing
new that is like this thing that happens
in the post-credits scene is like uh
yeah we that's what he who remains was
talking about but there's nothing new
it actually changes literally nothing
and it doesn't even succeed as being a
standalone Ant-Man movie and it doesn't
really do much new for setting up phase
five either even
it felt like a cartoon I see other
people saying it feels like an SNL
scratch I found a coined that I said
that first it was him but uh yeah koi
what did you think of the because John
and I talked extensively about already
on the channel what did you think of the
big credit scene I saw you like I don't
know what you felt the second time
around but I remember when it ended you
went yeah
you went down
I did visibly okay so my thing with
Jonathan Majors is he's got this really
quick recap in case people okay super
quick Recaps 30 seconds on what happened
in the microwave so basically the mid
credit scene is the Council of Kings
gathering around basically discussing
the events of the film in real time
about their impact and how they must
call all the kangs for because they're
starting to touch the Multiverse so the
kangs are aware of this event occurring
and they know that they need to do
something to change it you've got a kind
of play I think it's the Scarlet
Centurion is what they're leaning into
for the first one introduced you've
definitely got Rama Tut and you've got
what might end up being a mortise I hope
that's not the mortise designed to go
with but you've got three uh kangs of
note and then they cut to a entirety of
Kang Council in this giant Arena and
they actually grab a frame straight from
the comic book literally down to the uh
last king that turns and yells at the
camera that's from the comic I enjoyed
that as a comic fan but as a movie fan I
went well that's weird out of context
um but it is uh a post-credit scene that
does set up something but my issue with
it is Jonathan major strength is that he
basically is able to play everything so
real and so grounded I believe it
Jonathan Majors can do the most
ridiculous accent and he can basically
the post-credits scene was a a Meisner
class in Hollywood and an actor being
like let me try these five different
characters but Jonathan Majors is so
good I'm in like Jonathan Majors can
literally change his Cadence and then
I'm invested and he can also do accents
and I'm always in but the issue was it
was so big times all of those characters
it felt like an SNL skit because there
wasn't any there wasn't anything around
me time to get used to these characters
yeah you're not able to it just cuts to
them it feels like a spoof out of like
Walk Hard when they cut to the Beetles
you know like we're all doing accents
and it's just kind of so it feels good
it's not his fault and to me well to me
the the scene too with the that you're
referencing within the comics there's
like an ominous build to seeing everyone
there because he's like in the darkness
and it's like who's there he's like
reveal yourself individual or something
and then it's cut to like oh there's a
massive amount of kings and then here
they're all like getting ready for like
a high school football game
take on like Gotham and I definitely was
bothered by that and I'm like I'm not
there's no I find the setup for Thanos
in the first Avengers movie that scene
leads more of an ominous mood than the
entire mid-credits scene and I feel like
even if you're excited by the context of
all the kings coming I the scene should
feel threatening and menacing and to me
it doesn't to me to you that's one and
two of this movie setting up Kang and
letting Kang be the guy leaning back in
the chair and and experiencing the depth
of all these things that's Kang as soon
as you've got Kang being like that it
loses what Kang is like Kang Kang speaks
in capital letters but it doesn't feel
like he's yelling it feels like he's
menacing okay cool I wanna I wanna John
I wanna get your thoughts on this John
John I want to get your thoughts John
you're in the center I'm here Dan v900
thank you for the Super Chat my friend
the original ending from a test
screening four months ago John was a
king escaping with Scott and hope
getting trapped in the quantum realm
which I thought this movie totally
pussied out on doing I'm truly baffled
the that was changed I do have a the
second view made me sort of appreciate
the ending a little more the mid credit
scene was rushed now John John can I try
to see you for me I feel like I feel
like there's some kind of weird joke
about to come and I don't know what to
expect right now no I'm just trapped up
I understand the ending bit of having
Cassie open the door because she has in
the very beginning say
um you know if I had a device like this
I could have saved you and I didn't
catch it till the second viewing because
it wasn't until the second viewing where
she says it at the beginning oh yeah she
says that that's what she says I get
what the movie's trying to do but the
moment still doesn't hit for me and I
felt like they totally chickened out on
what could have been a good ending but
John do would you have preferred this
original ending
ah yeah I mean it certainly presents a
more interesting Prospect and a more uh
striking a bit of peril and continuation
for the Ant-Man movies going forward I
feel like they wrapped this up in a way
where you could kind of happily ever
after them if you wanted to uh and you
know maybe then we just see Cassie
moving forward so yeah I mean it it did
feel like a bit of a
again third viewing everything worked a
little better but it is one of those
things where after a tandem of very
conveniently timed events this is
perhaps the most conveniently timed
event because it even Scott and hope
they literally go let's go home and then
the portal opens behind them and you're
like did you know she was gonna do this
did you hear it was there a tingling so
yeah I I I don't like hate the choice to
bring them back immediately at the end
but I am still kind of taken aback and I
think it would have been a more
interesting Prospect to have them
trapped there because then that would at
least give me some kind of lingering uh
uh reason to think about you know like
what's gonna happen with Ant-Man and the
wasp and stuff like that
Olivia's trying to trigger you not yet
my issue and I've seen a few comments
about like where you guys are haters
like Last Jedi or I saw some dumb [__]
uh but I think that last Jedi Rocks Jedi
is the best
right I saw your list on Twitter today
oh do you agree I don't think it's the
third best I think it's I legitimately
do I think I think it's the let me think
about this for a second yeah I think
it's important I think yeah I was hoping
to have this debating anyway
[Music]
uh basically we're not we're not
anti-marvel I think that what we want is
we don't want to accept mediocrity
because then we'll get mediocrity I
think the reason they delayed the
Marvels is because the stakes are higher
for the Marvels now the Marvels comes
out in November as opposed to July
Guardians has been done and that's going
to wreck all of us I think Guardians is
safely gonna be amazing but I think now
they've had phase four be ups and downs
and I was the biggest Defender watch
anything in koi's comic Corner anything
in this channel I was saying like hey
they have a plan we should wait we
should pay off and the thing with film
structure is the First Act is going to
be set up the second act is catalyst the
third Act is resolution and climax so
the second act needs to be more cohesive
my concern is
this week um my concern is that it's the
kickoff to phase five so the stakes are
higher because this is the beginning of
change so the reason I'm way harder on
this film is because this was supposed
to be the Catalyst to make things evolve
and change and literally this is more
Oculus and more removed than any of the
Phase 4 Films if you actually look at
the ramifications of this there's less
consequence so if this is the thing that
is effectively the beginning of a new
arc and the beginning of the
introduction to our phase five villain
it is a lot more of a a big deal that
this feels so mediocre so if we accept
mediocrity we'll get Mediocre Films so
the reason I'm so much more angry and
the reason I'm so much more spoken and
I'm not as usually this um uh vocal with
my negativity is because there is a
point where positivity causes harm to
the product and the art I love so much
both the product and the art being
separate things so there needs to be a
ramification and thus we're being more
open about it it's not negativity for
negativity's sake it's to cause the
consequence of change
can I ask you all a question to the chat
as well as you guys because I've heard
differing opinions and I spent some time
on Thursday just chatting with fans
outside you know just like people who
are enthused but aren't critics did you
take this because I can understand this
feeling inconsequential if we think that
we will never see this iteration of Kang
again do you think that Kang the
Conqueror this king is made to return or
do you think they are setting up a
different Kang will be the bigger batter
version on the way I think Kang gets
absorbed into time itself in a way and
he comes back as a wielder of time to
bigger scale I think that wasn't his
death that was him uh melding with the
fabric of time and when he comes back
he'll be stronger but it will be that I
think I'm not one of the guys in the
arena nobody know because because some
people think it's gonna be the one guy
in the arena who's screaming yep
I wanted to be the guy that like Power
Rangers post no I think that made Majors
uh one of the coolest things I heard
from Majors describing that Kang was uh
what would a man who could speak every
language sound like and I'm like that's
the guy I want to meet and I feel like
the de-powered version because of him
being out of space and time doesn't
allow for that so he put so much work
into this character and it showed I want
to see that guy get to flex true true
facts I'm gonna keep this uh stream
moving here
oh what the hell uh star star Walker
star Walker star Walker thank you for
the Super Chat your support is greatly
appreciated today how long was Squad in
the quantum realm during the blip again
five years but it felt like five minutes
or something to him right he said
something like that because that Quantum
math seems off if Janet was down here
for 30 years right am I missing
something
that's a great Point that's a good
question I'm not my biggest qualm with
Janet in this film is her whole thing
about
Don't Go Near The quantum realm don't
even look at it don't talk breathe into
it so to talk about it don't take a
Polaroid of your device but in the
Ant-Man and the WASP post-credits scene
she's like yeah we're gonna send you in
there Scott are you gonna collect some
DNA hey Morty yeah
I don't know about this I don't have
enough pin particles weird time to be
doing Justin Royal in person but uh no
this is our audition to replace him but
to me that was the that part was it kept
nagging at my brain of this doesn't make
any sense to me it was this continuity
there's a lack of continuity somebody
just asked I'm sorry we do do Spotify
and this will be up there pretty soon so
keep an ear out you can already hear the
uh non-spoiler reviews up there uh
literally uploading right now in real
time whoa is that crazy whoa you can
catch up now it's insane thank you star
Walker Janine what's up saw this movie
today I'm glad you did Chavez and thank
you for the Super Chat and I honestly
loved it and that's fantastic yeah I'm
jealous I'm rooting for people to love
it I want people to enjoy this movie
and fight with me in person about it in
person online you're being a coward
find me in person and argue with me and
then you'll find me going yeah man glad
you liked it
I want someone to find me at Flogging
Molly this year just like last year and
get in my face about this just like they
did about that pedophile movie and I
want that to be weird and uncomfortable
it was that one that got nominated for
the Oscar oh licorice pizza
I appreciate everyone who contributes to
Super Chat today because koi is
disturbing to get this video demonetized
I was like I really appreciate the super
chats and streamlabs
um I like that holes joke but then they
kind of Beat It To Death povin Meyer
thank you for the Super Chat hey guys I
got a question for you both yeah I'm
spitting this off the top of my head
um what of King Dynasty is in Kang's
past but the Avengers future and he's
already experienced those events before
being exiled in the quantum realm you
know Koya recommended a comic uh that I
I it was I was such a fast read uh form
like for me I loved it yeah it's just
called King the Conqueror who's the
freaking writer I always forget it
Jackson Lansing Jackson Jackson lands in
and to me when I read that I I was I
found myself going I hope this is what
Kang Dynasty is because it's essentially
about it's a following a young Nathaniel
Richards who discovers time travel after
living in a great Utopia where like
violence was all he's just bored out of
his mind it's like an anime character
who's bored and looking for adventure
and then
and then when he time travels he meets
himself and he's like this guy's a bad
dude I can't be this dude and then you
watch The Journey unfold and I won't say
this is the setup and to me I was like
this is such a fantastic way to get to
know King and that's more along the
lines of what I'm I'm hoping Marvel will
do something like because you say king
dinosaur like well this would still fit
that because you're still meeting Rama
Tut you're still meeting other king
names that I don't recall at the moment
but sure he is
layer in there I I thought it was an
amazing comic book and and so if there's
a king to conquer because I I read I
read the King Dynasty
my favorite my favorite chapter in King
Dynasty is the one where there's no text
oh yeah that's a beautiful it's powerful
yeah for most of it I'm not a mage I had
a long talk with Chloe I'm not a big fan
of a lot of the event Comics well
there's a time when they just were dense
to be dense and there was also a writing
style that doesn't really translate to
now especially with Kang where it's like
why am I reading like a um like a book
you take out of the library like like a
lot of information and with a lot of
action yeah
yeah and I'm like and then the action
feels even more repetitive when you're
just looking at pictures uh but I do
think that with Thanos having his own
movie at Infinity War it'd be cool if
they went even harder with that exactly
describing that because Jackson
lansing's book it came out in 2021 you
could probably get it at your local
comic store right now still it is
beautiful it is uh atmospheric it's a
love experience about time and love I
know I think it could beautifully tie
into the Hue who remains and the Kang
we've met so far in a way that would be
really unique and I think Marvel can
really right the ship and I love your
idea here I I've talked about before I
think that a lot of phase four is going
to be uh surprising in that there's
things out of time like the I think
we've already seen movies that don't
take place in the time we think they do
so this would totally tie into that
early fun life fantastic
Dan v900
John
I'm setting you up here cool I'm gonna
alley oop you here with a question your
hand is the answer ready to shoot the
ball damn v900 back at it with the super
chats thank you Davy 900 you're being a
top contributor today I'm gonna hit a
random button
Kane can't be taken seriously as the big
bad now honestly don't worry the next
one will be the real threat is what they
keep saying right the make credit scene
was a joke Majors yes not served well
with the writing at the end what do you
think
um I mean the mid-credit scene yeah is
it's weird like watching the movie the
third time the humor of the whole thing
bolstered that in isolation
however uh yeah I still think that
because the movie is splitting the
difference between the tones doing the
humorous you know Ant-Man stuff but then
crashing it into this Shakespearean
warlord story uh I I do think it muddies
the water at least like I I am not
sitting here going like well they
totally ruined Kang and now I don't care
to see him anymore like yeah is it what
everybody wants and is it the most
agreeable take is he best served by the
writing I don't necessarily think so I
feel like you can comment more deeply on
the nuances of how they wrote him but
for for what it was like even the second
time honestly like uh the third time I
should say I didn't have as big of a
problem with the way they vanquished him
because it it started to read much more
like a big team effort like okay the
rebels came in and they had to take out
the kangbots and then uh Hank comes in
with all the ants and stuff like that
and then uh you know giant man is like
punching him and they're slowly
dismantling his suit which from what I
understand about Kang he is a brilliant
mind but the power comes from his
machines and things that he's built not
from an innate telekinesis or anything
like that so I bought in real time the
way they were able to wear him down and
as a collective Army overpower this guy
I know I know you're gonna hate this
Olivia I get it a bunch of ants took out
Kang I understand it in logical sense in
the grand scope of things
overarching piece of a big
interconnected thing yes it is a
questionable decision in isolation of
this movie I had a lot more fun with
what they wanted to do as an ant family
adventure but yes uh to be like this is
the big threat that I'm gonna take
seriously I guess they I mean it's clear
from people's responses that they are
going to have to work to bridge that Gap
some and because he who remains had an
innate quirkiness and by contrast King
the Conqueror does not he is he's
seething with rage and and sorrow and
Pathos and then the rest of the Kings
just all feel kind of silly so I feel
like they have set this weird table
right now where I don't know what the
next iteration of Kang's gonna be really
but I still think Jonathan Majors sells
it so hard and yeah that that
I love having Olivia in the chat
I love it
like part of me wants you in this stream
to throw down but part of me is like
thrilled that I can just glance over on
because John will get the most defensive
if you make a joke about him so it's the
most fun yeah no I know I I know that
myself like if we make a joke about you
oh and Olivia makes a joke you'll laugh
that's react John can get more a little
more defensive yeah and then I just will
yell at you both when the camera's not
that's true yeah as soon as we rap okay
wow Greg can take a joke but then when
the camera's not rolling then it's like
I am reconsidering you being part of
this why are you on the real rejects you
said two swears uh I will also
acknowledge that I I agree with
everything you're saying and I think
it's really important that also people
saying like why why did you make four
videos about this if you didn't like the
movie or why are these things I think
that when you don't like something it's
more important to also quantify like the
the impact of what didn't work again
like I said in that rant like I think we
love this world and we want it to be
better so I think that like the delays
are a good thing the doing less shows
are a good thing but again clearly
they're uh listen thing like the the
Marvel world only works because Kevin
feige clearly listens to the fans
because Marvel clearly goes like ooh
just here or just here in real time so
if we keep going like Yay blindly then
it's not gonna get true so true so I
think these are important conversations
to have this is a moment where I just
really hope they don't take the wrong
lessons from people's responses that's
all because I feel like it could be very
easy to to find the wrong message from
what people are are responding to I
agree all right when I start to scroll
up yeah I was I amazed I did 900
back at it read that John doesn't have a
backbone enough for what oh this is
getting real I like it
he's trash
koi too oh we're gonna see John fume
today no I fully admit like yeah the
third time I had the experience I was
hoping to have all along Olivia you're
leading to us not moving on now
almost 100 did anyone have a real Arc in
this film nope no definitely not I I
can't I will there's not a single person
here who can tell me that there was an
arc I don't I can't even see a
justification and guess what even Thor
love and thunder had a character Arc
even Iron Man 3 has a character what
else is a bad received one I don't
remember Thor the Dark World enough is
there a character Arctic there maybe I
think he goes from violent to violenter
and James becomes goes from being like
in control to silly there's there's
something there no one has a character
Arc this would have been perfect here's
what my pitch for what if they just did
what the trailer was then they would
have had a character Arc if it was oh
Cassie and Scott have a troubled
relationship because it would be like
all right even though Scott's back
Cassie it's kind of happens like weird
subconscious abandonment issue she's
still at five years without her dad and
she went down a different path during
that time and she still hasn't fully
resolved her [__] bam you gotta set up
for a character there and then Scott is
consumed by his own ego with wanting to
be famous that's literally what the
trailer seemed like it was doing and
that he's not really there for his
daughter I thought in the movie when
he's like I just want to be there for my
daughter and then cuts to Cassie that
you would see oh he's just bullshitting
the world he's not really there for his
daughter that much and then as they go
through this journey through the quantum
realm then you watch as their
relationship changes that thing that
where the trailer splice together the
the flashback with Janet and the
conversation with Kang to make it seem
like Kane was offering Scott the chance
to be with his daughter that would have
created a family conflict and a nice
Dynamic that way that Dynamic would have
been like there's a conflict within the
with the ant family of Scott you don't
know what you're doing you can't trust
this guy it would have created a debate
around the goal are you saying that the
only Avenger in phase three that lost
time with his family in that direction
should have had the only villain in the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
introduced so far wheeled time as a
threat yeah time is the thing all they
had to do with the trailer like whoever
made the trailer clearly had like I know
what a better movie of this would have
been to give it a character Arc and some
stakes and what's hard is Peyton Reed is
such a comic nerd that he he probably
wanted that story enough he planted
those seats and what it would and what
you could have done for wasp who is not
a character in this movie what you could
have done for wasp is have her be trying
to be a stepmom right but but Cassie
can't connect with her right boom you
got character
if you put Hank by himself right you
move Hank over here and he's and he's
going to talk to his aunts and have his
land Adventure which would be a fun
little side mission a c plot with Hank
yes allows hope and Janet times they can
actually have a motherly bond which
would parallel Scott and his daughter's
Bond and have a fun little dichotomy and
that at the end would have served the
ant moment even more and it would also
allow a lot of interesting moments where
the end of this movie should have been
right the first movie's called Ant-Man
right yeah second movie called Ant-Man
and the WASP because they finally let
Evangeline Lily do something make the
third movie Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumavia into the movie with Hank Pym
and Janet Van Dyne trapped in the
quantum realm they're wandering off to
rebuild that City with people and the
title comes up and it's Ant-Man on the
WASP but it's Ant-Man Hank Pym and the
WASP man at Van 9 trapped in quantumania
and then there's stakes and then it
makes
I can't remember your last name but Evan
in the chat said that uh the coffee shop
guy had an ark he did he was the only
one he learned Modoc has an arc
don't be a dick
um Gannon fish I love your name thanks
for the Super Chat hey Coy hey you were
mad at the fax X trailer launch and he
was so kind what happened to King at the
end any theories he's he's big and small
at the same time he's Modoc now he's
yeah actually that I would me weirdly on
board the next time he appears it's a
little okay yeah and it's like a little
blue hand but Jonathan Majors is still
doing the same exact serious performance
yeah and yeah I would be totally down I
think Kate gets trapped uh in time
itself and I do think he comes back
personally he got beat by ants I didn't
agree with uh so I didn't agree with how
he went down and I didn't agree with him
solely relying on his [__] Army like
that was something that made no sense to
me that he would because people were
like yeah I had some people I heard some
people defend this movie going but you
see can get dirty and he goes down there
and [__] people up I'm like he does
that for like 15 seconds after sitting
and watching also like I told you guys
when we first walked out I was like is
Kang's weakness big people
he literally looked out the window he's
like oh no he's big now I've seen a lot
of the quantum realm but nothing like
this nothing like a microscopically big
small man I'm gonna throw out a quick
Theory here I think the rings of his uh
of his ship are related to the ten rings
and the bang
because they have the runes on the
outside so I think I think my time
relates to the Bengal and the ten rings
so I think that we find out in like
phase five I totally agree but I thought
we'd find out a plant of that here I
thought we'd have a seed of that yeah
all righty guys thank you Mickey for the
Super Chat
hold on I gotta read my text all right
happy wife happy life I will say like
like I guess the point of my of my
change of partial heart is is the movie
is way more enjoyable but there are
these road signs of missed opportunities
left and right I think it's where the
story and the scripture tangents when
I'm trying to keep I think it's better
to enjoy it sad focused here correct
trying to keep it focused I mean half
the audience is happier being critical
the other half is like why can't you
just enjoy a movie this movie has a 50
of course it's going to be divided in
the chat 50 is great because that's true
divisive it's not mad it's true devices
we were missing the homies we were
missing the homies we were from the
first to seven out of ten we were that
is the thing that is the gripe I I
actually care about and I'm legitimately
bummed out about do you have no Luis
recap or anything like that do you have
do you have a way to bring him in I had
I had a whole thing I thought he was
gonna be there at the end being like so
wait a minute like like recap the whole
movie like like that's what you did like
or maybe he shows up at the book signing
like he didn't even come to come to the
side I wanted David to smulch in reading
the book in broken Russian I wanted uh I
wanted Luis
tell us what happened in the five years
Paul Rudd was gone can you imagine like
and he but what he does is he gives us
all of the MCU shows so all the MCU
shows that people that just watch the
movies don't know he basically like
spits those out that would have been so
much fun there were so many
opportunities you know what I think a
good post credit scene would have been
instead of what we got is him talking to
an Avenger about instead of him brushing
off like yeah no big threat you know in
the ending you're like don't worry about
everyone I think what good post credit
scene would have been him talking to an
Avenger and warning him about it that
way it feels like a real that way it
made it feel like the movie's important
like guys and like that same ominous
tone could have actually worked at
someone I don't want to forget our
stream Labs so I'm gonna we got two
right now so I'm gonna like quickly hop
over to here
did I do it should have been yeah you
can also use this but should have been
Sam Wilson cap in the big screen I
appreciate your help here John
thank you
just to recap
I can't tell if Coy liked it more the
second time or not John liked it more
the third time and uh I'm about the same
that didn't really change
I'm like love and Thunder
I really didn't like it that much the
second time but I liked the first half
more the second time in the second half
less so guys Gareth heart a Garth
Harkness McMurray thank you so much for
the stream stream labs are actually
better because of the fact that they
don't take as much a cut because you
know YouTube is like a mafia invading a
town Mark Oliver we love you YouTube
please
Mark Oliver Everett of eels is the guy
who wants Scott to take a photo with his
dog what makes this Cameo inch guys fun
fact what makes this Cameo interesting
is that E's father e e Everett Everett
Hugh Everett the third is the Quantum
physicist who first proposed the many
world's interpretation MWI of quantum
physics incredible yeah and this movie
really takes advantage of that's a
really cool thank you I didn't know that
that's a really cool fact that that is
that is a real Cameo and also Ryan from
BuzzFeed unsolved has a cameo
that's who it was I couldn't pinpoint
who is that guy but I kept thinking of
movies yes you're right the second you
said it I was like that's who it was uh
Curtis Mason here after Doctor Strange's
mom got several spoiled in the trailers
I started only watching the first
trailer for Marvel movies
um thank you for the Streamline I
believe it has helped me to have a
better experience with Thor four bp2 and
Ant-Man 3. Thor 4 is still too silly
though I love the caveat of like I've
enjoyed these Thor four still not so
great but yeah uh Curtis uh also Curtis
good to see you uh I think that not
watching the trailers is the healthiest
way to enjoy any of this we're just
stuck on the internet guys you know I
gotta level with you man it doesn't
really change that much for me like I
saw like every trailer and leak and
thing for Spider-Man no way home and
that more than delivers yeah uh Black
Panther 2 saw like every trailer I love
that movie well if the thing is good
enough the spoiler or one tamper the
drama yeah no I mean I I I I just wanted
some basics
I just wanted some characters in here
you know it's not I'm not asking for a
lot you know what I mean all right they
also set up characters it's not like the
movie didn't have the opportunity like
Paul Rudd's dialogue throughout the film
about him and his daughter and time
never landed and that's really difficult
for me yeah yeah look how much ketchup
we have to do here I stopped talking
very quickly it's awesome how much
ketchup we gotta do I'm Gonna Keep Us on
track don't you wait
I mean don't you I mean I won't do wait
okay I'll wait
all right guys check it check it here's
what cam K is saying
um yeah you can see your name right
yes whatever thank you for the Super
Chat Kanga beat by the ants that's
minimalizing the fake that the fact that
King actually got beat by a class two
technocratic civilization oh no release
size extremely intelligent answered
thousands of years advanced technology
give credit fair enough they they are
incredible this is King the Conqueror so
here's what I'm saying though if these
ants already exist he's conquered them
like okay I'm saying the you just had to
if you have that rather than just having
them show up if you have ants and then
Avengers
Fight King it's they're probably it's
going to be no problem it's gonna be not
a problem I I issued it was phase three
batchrock left killmonger killmongered
in phase four gore did not Butcher and
so far Kang has not conquered I'm having
trouble with my verbs what is uh who's
who's the worst king of them all I mean
probably the guy that turns and screams
at the camera on the post credit scene
oh the worst is the most scariest yeah
well mortise is the scariest it is a
mortise okay which one sucks the most at
his time the one that just yells well
you see yeah I mean I don't like the
payoff in the moment of it especially
because I feel like Michael Douglas was
kind of just walking through the whole
movie he likes ants
falling down I want to watch falling
down and then just have scenes where
he's angry I like ants I like it people
saying Kane killed all those ants he
still got over taken by oh he he's he's
the guy who's apparently beat this is
the king that was so bad that got exiled
someone defends it saying it actually
could be an unreliable narrator he's
saying that but the movie but you know
but that might not be it I'm like okay
you're giving the movie a little more
credit I'm going what the movie gave me
so bad he got exiled and he's so
intelligent he builds his army that he
wants to take up to Earth so that way he
can start conquering again but this Army
got taken down by apparently this
Rebellion that was never strong enough
to take him down before a giant guy a
wasp and a bunch of ants like and I feel
like King
if the ants have been around there for
that long wouldn't Kang have been
intelligent enough I mean he not Intel
that sounds like I'm undermining I'm
saying Kang
the character that at least it's been
told for me
would have been aware of the ants right
he would have wanted him Landing as soon
as they'd landed Bill Murray even said
like he knows you're here because I know
you're here he'd know about the ants
like there were so many people in movie
logic my question then becomes because I
what I've noticed every time from the
first time on is that the ants each
activate some odd it almost feels like
they do a shrink when they're going
through the quantum portal that none of
the other ant Family characters do so
they have those little helmets so I took
it as they go to like a sub subatomic
place which it still seems like Kang is
omnipresent and knows everything but at
the same time that red is I guess maybe
what they were trying to communicate is
they went even further down than
everybody else did and so maybe they
were able to just kind of do their thing
it might have been fine too in the final
battle if if it looked like King was
actually winning in the fight at first
also if the ants took out his minions
there would have been some symmetry of
like the idea that Kang needs uh this
civilization to for him to rule and the
end need to take out that Civilization
like there were parallels that could
have worked because the Ant-Man scene
where he became ants through the the
division of reality and probability him
mirroring ants was fascinating you could
have had that same mirror with the ants
taking out the colony that Kang built
because he is a conqueror a colonizer he
could have had that colony of ants take
out his colony and then our family take
out Kang himself but instead they didn't
play with any metaphor they just had him
get run over by ants true listen
um koi we're not on the new rock stars
break room okay I think it's important
you you look to the camera a little bit
more I keep reading eating angry or or
you know what you can't why are you
kidding don't look at the history
[Laughter]
up up down what eight one four 99 of the
people who say stuff mean to you online
are not going to say it to your face in
person and the one that tries all right
not everyone's Olivia Olivia
she's been in here yeah she was just
like where's the script yeah
sure that's the credit I'm giving that's
why she's a real one that's why you're
married we love her I'll cry that's
Olivia up up down
she knows it's gonna get to you
my name is Darren and I'm not a dick
Modoc works so well for me and the
audience basically laugh at every joke
with him Darren all right I know it's
funny like in the first screen people
hated him but I loved Modoc especially
in the second time like you know what
screw it I wasn't sure if I really loved
him on the second time we're like I love
this guy he's funny he's the only one
with an arc he's lying about people look
at me I'm such a dick like it's a great
delivery tell me what to be no his
deliveries across the border perfect
yeah even the line where Scott is like
Derek Darren and then he goes Modoc yeah
yeah like I even the one word deliveries
when he pops up I don't know why was the
only one that left in every screening of
this but when he pops up outside of Hank
pym's uh helicopter he goes
that's so funny to me hi Hank so good so
yeah I loved him uh he's my favorite
part of the film and David is small
Chin's little little holes guy and his
his line too because like the first line
of you were always like a brother to me
and I was like that's kind of funny but
when he caps it off with at least I died
so funny
yeah yeah that's how it works yeah I
feel like he's dying just let him just
let him have it so funny that was and
then they have like the all right
because like we already had such a funny
death with Deadpool 2 when he kept dying
yeah that I'm like okay they might
actually do something different that I
that I thought also visually if you
re-watch the first Ant-Man it's so
perfect that they made him Modoc with
his little arms like it's yeah
of an in-universe change to An Origin
where they really made the most out of
something and when they recap that and
they're like oh wow the way you shrunk
down it makes perfect sense I loved it
Leia Ariana Bonnie great name
um
yeah it's a great name Star Wars in the
MCU King had Vader Vibes love it
kind of I feel like he should be more
Palpatine though he's not really Vader
to me I agree that it felt star warsy
and I agreed that in the first two acts
there were definitely Vader Vibes with
like his presence walking down hallways
in the cape and there were there were
elements I totally see but I think that
we should meet a more Emperor Kang next
hopefully like he should be pulling
strings and I I think um
the other the uh the other part about
when people say it's like Star Wars I I
don't know I I I absorb all the Star
Wars movies I've seen the animated shows
so when I hear that I go there's some
stuff that has like a production design
quality that looks like Star Wars but to
me it doesn't really feel like Star Wars
to me the when people say that I I I I
subconsciously just disagree
I think it sounds like Star Trek you
know in a way and I think it has Star
Wars set pieces but I I think Star Wars
is more of a of a an adventure uh like
the score to Star Wars is what I feel
like it's more of like a hope and wonder
and more of a fantasy so there's more of
the Sci-Fi remember Star Trek's more a
little more heady than Star Wars but
it's more is more ethical quandaries and
then Star Wars is more swashbuckling oh
I like that I think John actually put it
best yeah that's really good call yeah
John with the words that's why you're
the center that's why you're in the
middle yeah it's like a mishmash of like
Star my friend described it as like a
mishmash of like Star Wars Mad Max and
Total Recall Mustafa jav this movie was
more out of place thank you Mr Potato
with no Heist so even then you could
have like enhanced that more if there
had to be a journey to get to what is it
called the or the big probability storm
no no the the actual device he's trying
to get the multiple engine yeah when
he's trying to get to that instead of
just dive and uh like I love the
probability realm sequence please don't
excuse that fact I love it but if there
was a little bit more of a focus as that
plot comes in so late yeah and there's
this unnecessary there's something that
I don't like about this movie there's
this unnecessary build that they treat
him like Voldemort when they just don't
say king's name it sounds like a nitpick
put her and it kind of is we know
they're always like he's coming him
everyone's just saying that and then
after you meet King everyone just calls
him King looks like they had to meet him
until they'd say it oh yeah like we know
what's happening yeah we've seen the
trailer this is not literally building
I'm very curious to know what somebody
who isn't as immersed feels about that
specific that is a good question someone
who might not have seen Loki and doesn't
know what to expect I wonder if that
works any better but I yeah I mean I
think I think they could have made a
heist element out of it if it was really
like and that would allow for Scott to
explore more of that way you see more of
the quantum realm because he has to go
through the quantum realm and encounter
all this [__] because I have he has to
work in order to get to this device then
I'm like boom then you get a really
explore and live in the quantum realm
they could have even had everyone get
sucked in the quantum realm except Scott
and then they could have had his boys
have to help him use the device that she
made to have him go through the quantum
realm and that could have been the heist
that could have used the team yeah that
could have been himself if I was there
with my family my daughter
like this boom better movies all around
first action and then you also allow for
the heist uh Corey M thank you for the
Super Chat the quantum Romans its own
universe so they're not tiny anymore
it's it's confusing rules yeah I don't
understand how we got big small but it
was different well I get it it's just it
it's just yeah when you go into a place
like this then the sense of scope
changing changes and diminish it's like
you're not in the real world blowing up
a Pez dispenser and being like oh wow
here you're yeah you're more sh you're
just in a different
complete realm where that stuff doesn't
apply the same way but is the
implication that he's actually giant but
isn't he still microscopic he's giant
relatively but right but but yeah I get
what you mean about the about the
physical aspect about like the yeah the
you know I'm so hungry like that I don't
quite because it's not like he traversed
I know it's a realm out of space-time
but I don't think that implies it's in
another parallel like I think the rules
would still apply because he's still
infinitesimally small yeah I'm curious
about that I've seen a lot of Echoes In
the chat too people saying they need to
ditch these Rick and Morty writers and I
I do I do wonder how much creditor blame
can be placed on the writers in a
situation like this because of how much
modular
just tweaking has to happen with these
movies and if you're in this position to
be a big setup in a big Avengers tie-in
movie you know like how how much flesh
can you put on that because like Loki
thought had really wonderful writing for
the most part same guy wrote Multiverse
Madness and I could feel how that needed
to be like reworked and retooled and
modularly so like I felt like that's
probably not really Michael Waldron's
full script on display or or so like I
have some level of faith that maybe this
guy who wrote this movie you know who's
apparently writing Kang Dynasty might
still turn in a great script for that
that isn't hampered by also pandemic I
assume played into this but yeah it
seems like they have time and it seems
like they're consciously making that
decision like I have a lot of Hope now
huh unlike this movie
where she showed up there's not a lot of
Hope
yeah that's how you transition when
you're in control of this side of the
screen SKR
this movie made me not feel threatened
by Kang anymore four out of ten you know
what I give a 10 out of 10 the fact that
you super chatted us thanks for the
contribution and yeah I don't really
feel that is that is the thing I'm not I
don't feel threatened by King anymore it
really bugs me I think they have to do a
lot of work they have to really fix a
lot because here's the thing there might
be a good portion of you that still love
that and still feel threatened I think
it has made a lot of people though and
you're gonna have to win people over you
just you are in the position now where
you have to win people over to feeling
threatened by him Jonathan Majors would
watch the movies
like I didn't watch it because of acting
choices it's which I believe I actually
do my same issue with Scarlet witch in
one division into the most ever since
Madness no no that's that's that is the
issue well whatever samanthus didn't
relate to One Division like her Arc not
just Justin Roiland Defender oh my God
who said that
[Laughter]
I'm playing into the amusement of the
absurdity of the claim I think in the
same way Multiverse undermined Scarlet
Witch this undermined he who remains I
think like it's the same level of
concern going into phase five that we
have like I don't know how they fixed
Scarlet Witch now and I don't know how
they fix Kang now
um I I think Scarlet Witch was great I
thought she was so much more scary and
met unlike whatever qualms you might
have with Scarlet witch from the
transition which I completely understand
feeling like there's a gap there I
understand that I think though the movie
greatly succeeded and she is threatening
in that film she is scary and uh like
when she's chasing them like when she
beats up the not just beats up
annihilates the five people
she destroys them and then is chasing
like they could not beat her in that
film that she had to make the choice to
quit like that's how that's how badass
she was at the end of the day I felt
more threatened by her than I did by
King every step of the way sure yeah and
so that's fair and I I agree there yeah
yeah
how do they figure it's look if you keep
killing off King he stops being scary no
I'm getting triggered by someone's car
welcome to the comments
why do you think we stick to Super
people are usually possible
73. gotta go to the gym after this yeah
I gotta work out again
that's an ad man I honestly had how you
doing John you're good William Moser on
the chat wants to make sure you're doing
good
traffic 73 don't worry we got here
chapeled up right in front of us as an
Ant-Man fan announcing I had such a
blast with this movie hell yeah I didn't
find Janet scene for secrecy a regular
some someone who suffered through trauma
but it did feel a slight bit too long
overall excited for the future hey man
as long as you had a good time I will
never try to convince you to feel
otherwise even if we are stating
opposite opinions throughout the stream
please know that is not us at least my
intention koi has a different intention
rage he always thinks he's in a massive
debate with you and he has to change
your opinion he's trying to manipulate
you John same thing especially John if
anyone knows John oh boy he is not I'm
glad you cannot have an open
conversation with John about anything
he's usually the biggest hater of them
all that's right koi's opinion does
change
always a page still James Gunn directly
messages him sure he'll be like hype up
DC and talk to him I just got a venmo
from James Gunn hold on yeah I got a gun
A gun
so what happened it's the DC logo
really quick just one really quick thing
uh my friend pointed out to me after
seeing this that she seemed to think
that what people seem to want out of
this movie is probably what you're gonna
get out of Guardians 3.
and I could absolutely see that in what
way in that uh this comes off as lighter
and sillier and doesn't deliver on being
these heavy steaks no one died no one
really went through any life-changing
alteration whereas Guardians is the
funny team who is now going to have to
deal with direct loss on screen a
heavier scenario for them that will be
less comedic though there are comedic
elements blah blah blah I really need
Guardians like that'll be my palate
cleanser that'll be like me feeling like
Marvel again sure Corey look at the
camera a bit too long okay now Corey for
this next time you talk I want you to
look at the camera without blinking all
right okay I just want you to give a
whole
sentence okay sentences is there is it
is there a question I'm building you up
okay you've got to get you to tears
Luke Bros thank you for the Super Chat
says the strongest King who got beat by
ants then I know that the other kings
are not a threat Doctor Doom has to be
the big threat now this ruin came from
the jump to this point to the point is
now A Minor Threat koi what do you think
do you think it's actually a thing to
build up uh I think that you blinked you
already blank you son of a [__] I'm out
you're out I'm out that's it I got no
answer all right you can just look at us
now okay completely answer the question
I want the profile here I I think that
basically in the comic books you got a
different medium right in the comic
books Kang dying has a different impact
than in movies dying it's the same
reason I personally don't want Steve
Rogers or Tony Stark to come back if
Tony Stark comes back I hope it's AI
because you can at least have a
separation of reality where he's blue
and digitized and if Steve Rogers comes
back I only want it to be as Old Man
Steve basically doing Stan Lee cameos
that implied that he is Stan Lee later
and therefore makes it Steve Rogers
watching over his people those are the
only ways I want them to come back
because if you have a variant of Steve
Rogers this just Captain America and
it's just played by Chris Evans the ark
and the loss of him is is undermined so
the medium of filmmaking allows you to
feel connected to the actors as well as
the character in a different way if Kang
keeps dying in a way that makes you go
like well he's not that important and
then you meet a big one you're still
going to have the memory the sense
memory of your experience with Kang all
those times the reason horror movies
work is because there's a part of your
brain that doesn't separate the
experience from real life you're able to
actually be afraid that same issue will
happen in the medium of comic book
movies because you're going to go like
I've seen this guy be pretty taken out
by ants so like it's not gonna feel like
you can separate those things so what
works in the comics doesn't always work
in the movies that's why their
adaptations not translations and that's
a really important distinction so if
Kang does keep getting taken out by
things that feel trivialized and they do
keeps going like the next one's the big
one eventually we're going to run out of
the ability to suspend disbelief enough
to believe that he's the big bad they
describe him as verses that we've
experienced him as that's very true koi
can you Flex for us I think there is
also just something about it is weird to
be in this position where you only get
one step at a time and they have a big
plan that spans so we can only react in
real time you know like yeah if we only
have that you can you're forced to
nitpick the plan in a way because you
don't know what the full scope of it is
right right like we won't know until the
end and I I kept saying I'm really
excited to re-watch phase four after
I've seen phase six but they still need
to make sure that phase four and five
earned that payoff so it isn't only good
retroactively like Age of Ultron got
better but when you look at Age of
Ultron there's a lot of flaws that never
even got solved true like tripping balls
Thor in that bathtub still doesn't make
sense it does in my head Canon that's
the Thor that we follow in Thor 11
Thunder think about that we're watching
two different times authorities
I like Taiko watini Thor just tripping
that makes so much sense I like that
that's what's happening right there I've
solved your love and thunder problems
it's just a head trip back to the stream
Labs here thank you to everyone who's
been contributing this means a lot I'm
pretty sure koi got us ready to
demonetized with this talks about
pedophilia
is cute
wow someone created me an account just
for you I'm honored that that makes up
for some of the rage thank you for the
streamlab king is not threatening
anymore man four out of ten let me ask
you guys this let me ask you a great
podcast question let me ask you guys
this
oh wait no I'm I totally skipped ahead I
will go back to you fly don't worry I
haven't forgot um let's say king is met
because it looks like in the in the post
credit scene for Loki season two that is
the King when he who remains is talking
there was a king with like uh like a
beard and a big hair and stuff that
looks Mr timely yes yeah yeah yeah but
I'm saying that he who remains when he's
doing like some presentation looked like
that was Victor timely in there
do you think if we see the Victor timely
then die
that's really going to undercut it do
you think they'll kill off Victor
timeline Loki season two oh I'm just
trying to Crave it out because we
already got that question from like
crazy yeah no no I that that if they but
appreciate the Streamline if they do
they at some point they gotta stop like
just killing because I I think I think
phase one we learned a lesson about just
killing villains like I feel like a
batchrock is the only like one of the
first villains to actually like become
an overarching villain and I get that
there's multiple kangs but I do think
there comes a point where if you just
kill him it's like why is this guy like
why why are we worried about that guy we
kill a lot right right so if they better
not kill timely because that would that
would I mean it could be the quantity
they could go with that that every time
you see a different ver because Kevin
feige has been like oh man so we're
gonna meet so many different versions of
this guy over all these movies so maybe
it's the quantity rather than any one
particular gang I don't feel like
that'll that doesn't sound like a
confident Prospect as I say it out loud
but you know maybe it'll kind of feel
like the gray minion problem in phase
one though where they're like we attack
all these guys and they're all kind of a
blur like I just don't feel like you
need a doom presence sure yeah you do
you need at least one who's that's why I
like the idea of the exiled one going
back and like actually like whipping all
their asses because then then it would
have been oh man this guy is scary yeah
all the other kings
um anyway flev Doran who's usually a
massive Marvel Defender just came by to
say hi thank you flood for being here
not much to say disappointed
yes that's what I want to hear everyone
who comes in here defending this movie
what's wrong with you people agree with
me that's how I live uh I like the
Ant-Man films like Catherine Newton just
watch the news SVN video that's funny we
John and I on patreon.com the real
rejects another great way to support the
channel is uh there's an episode with
Catherine Newton which really made both
of us go it seems like they saw this
episode and went she should be Cassie
Lang would have been she's phenomenal in
that episode and it's exactly the kind
of character that I wish Cassie was more
like what's different just I'm out of my
curiosity oh you know she has struggles
she has to learn how to beat she's
trying to be a hunter and she's learning
how to act she's she's making a lot of
terrible mistakes along the way even
though she's capable and has potential
she she kind of carries that I feel no
sense of Trauma from Cassie Lang they
make in this movie whereas like in the
show like there's a sense of trauma even
though like yeah you got your dad back
and everything you still have that five
years they do make her the most
agreeable least uh yeah you know
conflicting version like like she's in
jail but for like reasons you almost
can't argue with and yes and I mean the
ark funny enough the ark is in there
it's just very s slight I would say that
yeah I mean I feel like what Cassie
deals with in this movie is just like oh
yeah I guess I get myself in over my
head before I really check to see if I
got this and right I should maybe know
that I got this before doing that and uh
yeah I okay that's what you're saying
there is yeah yeah it's down there it's
buried it's yeah and it's like they
present this interesting opportunity for
her to be falling into Scott's past and
his presence simultaneously and they
never present that and also they don't
do much with it yeah there's never a
moment where Scott identifies with his
daughter during the Freedom Fighters
fight which was just set up to parallel
her being in jail to help the people in
the beginning like they never actually
acknowledge in a way like the freedom
fighter stuff is so clearly like help
the little guy he wrote a book about the
little guy and then and then she's also
like you don't help people that aren't
directly in front of you I'm like those
are all the things that make up a good
plot but then it Never Lands yeah it
does it never becomes about Scott
wanting to help the rebels and
anything they should have given that to
Janet right because Janet abandoned them
at least in their perspective that's why
I want her to stay like Janet they set
her up for a character Arc to redeem her
because I understood it on the second
time around like oh yes like she helped
Kane get just far enough and then they
had to deal with him and then she left
so I understand why she feels all this
guilt about the situation and the
secrecy yeah and so I'm like oh then you
should have probably given something to
her to like go I'm gonna help them out
now that's why I thought them retiring
to the quantum realm like Florida that
would have been cool true true Caleb
Caleb here's what Caleb has to say
hey you
thank you for the super streamlab by the
way they're better than super chats
probably won't take this compliment
seriously but I genuinely think you guys
are great mail
as in real time as possible it's amazing
sure so that you are correct you set me
up
the way you guys speak openly the way
you guys speak openly and honestly about
your thoughts and feelings and your
appreciation of one another is inspiring
that is so kind man thank you
appreciation I don't deserve that but
thank you
um we do appreciate each other I won't
even let this be sarcastic this is like
I love doing this for these guys and
honestly like I've said from the
beginning the reason I like these live
streams is I do feel like I can be my
most authentic self and that's because
of these guys and it's because of like
the most the audience like I know I get
angry at nothing which is my own issue
but like overall this audience is
absolutely incredible he is not faking
this yes
[Laughter]
appreciate you guys
thank you Caleb thank you thank you
that's really sweet of you and yeah I
think um I think these guys are okay
I mean if you knew me in real life I'm
not a good male role model but but yeah
I very much appreciate the love John is
a great
model I am a moiled it's a good railroad
you need to be circumcised
yep
I know it because of Weird Al actually
yeah a pretty fly for a rabbi I like how
it comes it took me years to realize
what a bar the parents pay the Moyle and
he gets to keep the tip is oh that's a
good that is a bar when you realize what
the actual context means anyway d-mod a
test Corey's dedication to passion is
his Pat what he's passionate about is
very impressive and John is honestly
probably the nicest guy you'll ever meet
it can uh can be frustrating yeah
Janine Devine Janine Janine the bean
machine
I liked the Pim Van Dyne length I think
I was going to bring you on the channel
Janine
you done shot yourself in the foot here
dear
if you disagree with us I don't know
respect
disposing opinions clang the clan
feeling like a team
yeah I like the potential for that I do
also like all the ants ant visuals as
they weren't very present in Ant-Man and
the wasp how'd that grow on you John I
know that was a real qualm because out
of the three of us John is the most
enthusiastic about the first two Ant-Man
movies I'll set you up for that question
again soon don't you worry son I got you
but yes the ending in mid credits deems
the film events seemingly pointless and
we lose second cool King we were
investing in
um but yeah I mean really quick uh
explain that thing that you were trying
to say about like when you deal with the
size and the Optics of changing yeah
like that's something I did feel was
missing because there's there's so much
fun about the first two where you're
watching like little guy in real world
exciting yeah and yeah you don't really
get a sense of that visually
um you don't get lost in The Wonder of
that I think in this movie yeah because
you're in the quantum realm and the
quantum realm is just a whole new place
with its own set of at least visual
rules and language and so you don't have
that familiarity to temper everything
it's not the charm of oh you're really
small in a in a very familiar kind of
commonplace like that Whimsy goes away
when everything is sci-fi Whimsy and so
that sense of scope and scale is hurt by
the fact that yeah like Kang's buildings
don't really look like actual buildings
and so the frame of reference that you
rely on to create the irony and the then
the humor of that and The Whimsy of that
is
it just needs something else to sell it
which I don't think is quite as apparent
here I feel like giant man is the thing
that gets to shine the most here they
don't do much in the way of like sizing
up an item and throwing it at somebody
like none of those things really happen
and I do miss them although I will say
the the thing that clicked about the the
partly about the third viewing is is all
that stuff at the end especially with
the ants and stuff it did read better
and it did feel a lot more fun because
uh everything got more fun and silly
that last ant moment is one of my
favorite Ant-Man moments in the entire
Trilogy I love when Hank shows up with
the ants honestly I think that's such a
moment I just don't like it's something
cost us it's silly it's very silly and I
get why people don't like it in this
movie's context but I think that
silliness the third time I was finally
able to enjoy that which is part of what
I want from Ant-Man and felt like was
missing the first couple tracks Kevin so
Kevin feige presented this at the lcap
yesterday and he referred to something
as like thanks for being here for number
31 excited to see you guys for number
32. and my co-host on koi cast is always
like they should stop calling them
Ant-Man whatever they should just call
them Marvel 31 Marvel 32. and it was
interesting to hear that from Kevin
feige for the first time and I think
this might be the first time where I
found it I need the 3x structure to also
feel like a 9x structure and I feel like
they did a really good job in phase one
through three making those bubbles work
but this was one of the first times I
was like this doesn't the cost of
building cost this movie its own 3x
structure that's true so that was my
issue I think with the Hank moment was
like I love that moment but it cost us
yeah yeah there are all kinds of things
you can flip-flop and somebody said like
I'm not asking it to be the same as the
previous movies with like regular ass
buildings I'm just saying they need to
bridge the gap of that part of the
fantasy with something else and that
doesn't really appear here anyway
I will stop talking in this live
streaming
John
get so defensive
as these things are fun to talk about
but I gotta we gotta move
would you do you know how many questions
we have I know I'm trying do you know
how often we could be reading a question
no often we fall behind to like we are
two hours behind here
I'm gonna have a serious conversation
with you right now
[Laughter]
yes sir
Greg is in control turn the camera off
of the comment section today
anyway
yeah
go go
this is my worst movie in the MCU thank
you all hail nflurry didn't care for any
character in the movie yeah
King's introduction to the mainstream
audience didn't match up to even if
there's even a one percent if one
percent of what the last episode of Loki
did this could have been better off
as a 50-minute Disney plus special
uh I don't agree with that yeah I think
this could have used a little bit more
time I think it could have been like a
220 like a good like yeah I think it
could have been like a good two hours
because we want to say 2 hours and 40
minutes and I'm like what do you think
you are John Wick chapter four yeah two
hours of fifty come on man yeah I think
20 more minutes with some of the things
we described really really helped it uh
I also it is less it is less than two
hours in fact it is an hour and 53 when
you get to the credits wow you notice
that on the third viewing right no I
noticed that on the second on the second
thing because Andrew was right next to
me and and the movie started after seven
and it was it was like um it was before
nine or something like that when we got
to the uh mid when we got to the just
the beginning of the credits not even
the mid credits scene yes so it is like
an hour it's less than two hours of
movie
Shenanigans Shenanigans I say all right
human target
that's what we call Koi around here
I keep thinking a Tron legacy down to
King behind clue enraging against the
surface world
and Janet taking the place of Jeff
Bridges
okay
the effects of Modoc reminded me of Jeff
Bridges
that's what I thought I thought of Jeff
Bridges and Scorpion King final fight
George Lopez from Spy Kids yes yes yes
yes
Greg got an accident
of course most of the darkness
let's all take a 10 minute break to do
bait Impressions people yeah
it was cool
but I wish the trailer story was the one
we got also happy to see cry throw koi
Thrive since movie fights that's true
it's green junkies days that's true man
yeah koi I've never I never fly you on
movie fights we did never fight a movie
never fought we could have we could have
been a great battle
very intense destructive movie fights
you just gotta have a great opening and
a great closing and the speed round is
my my clothes
that's the trick to all debate yeah the
middle of meander all you want yeah
close it up how you close that one and
three are the most important people stop
listening in the middle yes alrighty
guys all right we're done with today's
stream
I'm just gonna cut a short
but I don't understand when people go on
live streams when people do live streams
and they don't read all the super chats
people do that yeah have you ever heard
this channel called
Rock there's a glitch dude there's a
glitch in the livestock
it happens on too many too many channels
too many channels they do it at whoa
look at that wowie oh my God Quantum
realm craziness oh my God
all right what are we doing you guys are
seeing behind the scenes this is behind
the curtain this is how it works around
here guys
um
all right speed round John answer the
questions in the chat that are happening
right now uh yes for sure I agree Harley
Quinn show does the Bane voice the best
I have to see it I've never seen Harley
Quinn but people love it I didn't know
that dude it's so good oh really yeah
like it's a I think it's the best DC
property since Nolan's Batman like it is
I think the best thing since people love
it I'm not really editing the stream
because I'm just reloading I know but
people are all I can see in the chat uh
rock star I agree Nicholas you are a
rock star uh Alison mellow you make me
say wow every time I see you uh David at
bikime uh let's laugh together LOLs Nick
Hogan you're invited too we can just
lull on top of one another
um
ooh finding the disappointment with the
mid-credit scene Force I can't see how
you think it was cringy or stupid it was
awesome one of the best credit scenes in
the MCU okay so that's that's I don't
understand how people can tell people
that how they feel is not how they feel
they're like I think that's my biggest
reason for getting angry in any Live
Chat is like it's a very odd thing to be
like I feel one way you feel the other
so you don't actually feel that way now
I know why people don't feed live chats
it's insane it's because it's like a toy
existence I feel like there is a strange
there is a strange equation of
experience because you see something and
and I feel like I don't know it feels
like the truth to you but at the same
time it's it's not objective it's all
subjective it's always what it comes
back unless it's Thor love and thunder
in which case
yes I'm not gonna I'm gonna resist the
urge to talk about that defend it John
I'm almost done loading you got a lot of
super [__] I I clearly like most of
phase four a lot better than most people
do so I like most of phase I think like
people dog phase four but I feel like
every I feel like people look back on
the first three phases and what they're
really thinking about is phase three
because phase three is so consistent
whereas pays this one and two
over the place and okay-ish to pretty
good movies all over the place and the
only thing phase four is lacking is a
definitive like Iron Man or something
like that where it's like this is a
flagship and and wakanda forever come
close to that but they are also hampered
by other things too phase two also has
the benefit of phase three retroactively
improving things and we again haven't
gotten to that point with phase four
having the benefit of except for Thor
the Dark World which has never been
solved they've just changed to that yeah
that's what I'm saying all the
importance can be added to these phase
four things and people just aren't
giving it that benefit
it worked silent
Olivia Hamlet
thanks for the Super Chat
every time you guys think I'm I'm not
allowing you to get something off your
chest that you want to say I know these
streams well enough to know it's
eventually going to come around yeah
Olivia Hamlin all the good questions
about the movie are probably addressed
by now fair enough thanks for the Super
Chat so just have a wonderful Saturday
you wonderful Beauties thank you so much
cheers to you g fuel I like the movies
just so I stay on theme but appreciate
your honest thoughts real koi Jacks for
Life new channel name there it is taking
it over that's what we're gonna call it
that's what we should name the podcast
boy what did I just say did you just
said
too many
Panther rules here we are in my opinion
still going I really I know I'm
regretting that I really love the mid
credit scene
I can see why people love it I'm happy
for him and if the silliness of the
overall experience is working it plays
better in isolation well some people
don't find it silly some people really
like it okay I got a question to mix up
the mid-credit thing really quick really
quick when I say really quick I hope to
God it's really quick no rants
they say they beat him like they're and
to my mind I was registering that as
the king that we just witnessed in
Ant-Man in the lost quantumania but
there are people me if that is the case
that makes the Journey of this film even
more pointless if that is the case but
do you who do you think they're talking
about
either one undermines KAG but I like the
first one I like that he remains concept
because at least that's clever like it's
more playful sure but I do worry either
one makes it so like who are those why
are those guys important right okay I
like that idea also it could be they're
talking about someone in Kang Dynasty
and we could see that scene take place
in that film we talking about a
different game all together oh my God
there's so many kings yes Nick Hogan you
can see that now
yeah yeah yeah barely moved we were able
to do it it's just the dispute it
Frank Shields
everyone I want you to know
I hope that we got another king a
version of King the Conqueror because
this is the definitive Kang version he
got beat by ants nope nope in the words
of Daniel kaluya nope
[Laughter]
underrated movie have you guys seen the
Pedro Pascal Hollywood
uh have you guys seen the the what is
that have you guys seen any of the Pedro
Pascal Scott just from SNL a couple he
is hilarious the the Hollywood quiz one
you guys haven't seen it I didn't bring
this up last live stream
I talked about the Hollywood yeah oh my
God
there's something in there that reminds
me of that but yeah Frank Shields I
understand apparently they specifically
said the exiled one and that mid-credit
scene so that would be the one but there
could be other exiled Kings but you're
right it's probably the one in the film
we just saw
accordingly apparently they talk about
Exiles yeah that's true yeah yeah
who remains created
but he seems to have more autonomy
that's interesting because that's all I
have to say about that same huh I wasn't
even thinking at that time oh sorry
shots ahead of the program
Michael logo let's do this buddy Mega
Loco
you're you're loco my impression
was that the variance of King will work
together to keep the dynasty
so the Avengers had to outsmart instead
of outnumber him or rather them it
pushes the heroes to think further
outside the box verse I like the way you
phrase this and I also agree
I don't get it
so basically uh it's it's not like we
described with the gray minions where
it's going to be a numbers game it's
going to be like the the the singularity
of kangs uniting with for like as a
front so the King Dynasty is like
what they've built but I do think they
also need a a figurehead to represent a
singular threat so the Avengers have to
think in a way that is both uh larger
than the threat collectively and
singularly and I think that'll make it a
different threat than Thanos but I also
think we need a Kang that represents
something as threatening as kanos for us
to feel the impact of what he's
describing did everyone here say canos
Josh that's the various
evil like that's
the variant toward The Infinity Gauntlet
is made from recycled materials
just like Mountain Dew PS2 yeah seven up
cream soda Sunkist yes which is spelled
sin kissed which bothers me Jones
Heather gear
thank you heather gear my dear
thanks guys for your time discussing
thank you for your time listening how do
you feel about introducing characters
like Kang initially in an MCU show first
that was awesome I loved his
introduction still one of the best
moments for Marvel for me do you think
they have done MCO show film crossover
as well so far not really they haven't
really done much for it and if you
listen to koi's Little transition about
one division to Doctor Strange I feel
like some might argue they didn't do it
so well I feel like there's still a lack
of I am very confused I'm very confused
about the direction because I love the
idea of like every character has and
within themselves their own Universe
because that's how Comics are every
character within themselves has their
own universe but the rules of everyone's
universe is so varied now where you have
uh the quantum sci-fi side you have the
god side with Thor you got like the
supernatural other God's side with Moon
Knight like there's this Marvel has its
own Afterlife with the veil that's my
point and like black panther has the
astral plane
um there's so many different ancestral
plane yeah Thanos so there's so many
different like elements here and
different worlds I'm like how does this
mesh together
exactly are they going to care to even
explain that like because in the comics
they don't really even care to do that
they just have like there's a there's a
common threat that has United The
Avengers
all the time
I think that they're doing a decent job
but I do think there's a lot of
confusion if you don't have at least the
backup of information we know more about
it than the average person so it's hard
for us to say I don't really know how we
are the Council of comics we know like I
don't know how the average person feels
about like who's this person like did
the post-credit scene impact people that
much that hadn't seen Loki you know what
I mean I I can't know that because I
love Loki uh no I I will say I talked to
somebody who who saw this without seeing
Loki and was uh was intrigued by those
okay by the mid and post well I think
the the Loki scene really does a good
job at at least even if you don't really
understand it makes you go I wanna know
right yeah it is a good job I'm making
you go I might not get it but I want to
understand this and uh that's one more
can you ask for mostly I get confused on
what kind of interconnectivity we're
supposed to expect because I feel like
they hyped us up for like these are
gonna cross over in a big way and it
hasn't been that like overt as of yet
because they didn't even have zombie
strains
expecting too much of that versus I'm
just gonna take an awkward standing
break what they're actually promising
also if they can if they can move so
many
shows here right we're
in firm two shows it might end up being
three but they said like it is Jeff
we're getting definitely two shows there
was up to five rumored in 2023. if they
can move those so flippantly how much
could they have connected yeah
um well and I mean obviously it has to
like I got that clearly didn't happen I
think you have to asterisk so much of
the TV the Disney plus and movies era
because it's all been mid-pandemic right
there is a different tone and just and
just other world factors affecting
things we should look at Greg because he
I'm just gonna put it in his live stream
well I'll look there
Brothers
I agree
I don't know I I like they're capable
yes but I I I don't find it as special
exciting I think Marcus and mcfeely are
also a factor the writers should also
like if you want to bring back the Russo
tone you need the writers that did all
of their films as well oh dude man if
they can do the gray man before the MCU
I love the grape it would be great I
love the great great man at that point I
want I I like The Gray Man a lot more
than quantumania not a big fan of gray
man really disappointed cocaine bear is
going to be a problematic one I have no
idea and we might do it
we might just censor the title and then
not show up in search
they might have they might have they
might have white listed the word cocaine
Bear on YouTube
James Argenta thank you James I think
this king will become the beyond our
also think it will be revealed Kang
Enterprises bought Avengers Tower
oh yes I feel like that has been a
theory I don't know I I like in Kang
Dynasty when they're like
in in uh in the King Dynasty comic run
one of the cool things about it is Kane
does show up
see the one hope I have
is if they're going off King Dynasty to
some extent because they always change
this [__] up is they've already beat
king before so they're like we got this
[__] right but King has learned some
[__] because he's been beat
they really undermine just how brilliant
his plan is and then he dominates and
it's a pretty epic moment when he
dominates like it's a bunch of comics
but then they have one comic where
there's I think it it's called there are
no words I think that's the name of it
and there's one comic where he does it
it's so Bleak and you could feel it like
you're reading a movie yeah where it's
only images and to me that's my one hope
of why they would bring back this Exile
King because he lost and it would make
kind of like how Loki lost and Thor but
then he comes back in Avengers even
though it was never really a threatened
by Loki it would still make this King
like I've learned a lot since then I'm
really I'm more than prepared yeah I'd
love that and I'd love if they do it
silently it'd be really beautiful if
they have that reflect in this that's a
way you could do an annotation like a 10
minute four minute like silent section
yeah and then he's like and I've had a
son
he's a Scarlet Center hang in there
you're coming up Hamza don't worry don't
worry hamsa there's a reason I try to
move this along and then it upsets two
people people on this stream for some
reason
728 I was hoping at the end of the movie
when they exited the portals that the
world would be several hundred years
into the future where Kang is King and
that sets up a five to fix things
hundreds of years wow some people get
excited about Rama Tut and I'm like
didn't the Fantastic Four beat him I
yeah someone in the chat said Ramen Tut
stronger than a mortise and I'm like I
feel like I feel like the reason he was
in the you know pyramid days yeah
middays there were no smartphones
uh I think that would have been really
fun and also the consequences we were
talking about but I even the point when
he came back and he like looked there
was a moment the first time I watched it
when he looked out at the little dog and
also the coffee was twelve dollars I was
like it'd be cool if they just went like
20 years in the future like just a
little bit oh yeah so there was a
consequence or you realize something is
off about this universe and that dog is
really This Woman's baby or something
when they looked at the dog I'm like is
he gonna talk like this but I was like
is it Cosmo like my brain left and I was
like no he's just back in San Francisco
yeah
what'd you guys think about nope I will
not derail us Eon blotch oh thank you
good to see you hey Bucky good to see
you buddy that's his real name Bucky
Barnes respect this movie is an 8 out of
ten for me hell yeah yeah I thought it
was pretty good not over the top amazing
and didn't love it but I liked it I
thought some of the jokes were hit or
miss and Kane was terrifying Ant-Man
grew 400.
[__] feet tall Diddy
I think you can measure it and um yeah
it was 400 feet exactly 400 microns of
how come I do have a question about that
guys allow me to pose a question here
how come he wasn't is there something
I'm missing I'm generally going to pose
a question here question incoming
what Craig's List
that's that's the code for I'm actually
asking a question now question is coming
we just accepted instead of text in real
life I just saw it I heard it okay is
how come uh giant man wasn't exactly
tired after he was giant man for a very
extended period of time because he was
still small but big but why was Cassie
then that's why this isn't working
I took that as it's her first time doing
the giant walk isn't she still tiny
still
uh 500 at least yeah there's no there's
no right there's no perfect way to look
at it because you're correct yeah it's
like technically most needed it
technically you would still have a tiny
person metabolism just altered for being
slightly bigger but you're still much
smaller than your normal I don't know
don't you think they were prepared to
have some form of citrus pill on them
that could easily be digested my friend
hit me to the hip to me to the fact
that's a drugs joke I didn't realize
that's like a Molly LSD oh yeah yeah
yeah I actually I didn't put together
with that you're totally right I love
that I didn't I love that I love drug
jokes Star Wars Sith thank you so much
do you guys think that King the
Conqueror didn't really die at the end
and maybe somehow survived or was he
like dead dead I mean if the other kings
are the better smarter ones and they're
saying he's dead I'm gonna take their
work for it but if he's not then it's
like okay I guess the Kings don't really
know anything and are not good at
fighting
[Laughter]
you know I feel like it undercuts those
kings then if they're like yeah he needs
to be alive for the sake of my faith in
in this Kang Dynasty but if I feel like
the other kings think he's dead right
doesn't that undercut their ability to
have some knowledge on [__] if they
believe he's dead oh yeah either way oh
I didn't even think of that yeah either
way it shows a weakness in Kang yeah
because either they're not as
omnipresent or he was not great yeah
gangbang
um yeah yeah cool hey he gets sucked
into a thing he can come back he doesn't
die die regalia Talon everyone I want
you to know this koi if Marvel hired you
for writing
would you or would you be I see more as
a consultant instead of the actual
writer if they hired me as like Story by
not like the actual typist uh I would be
uh interested because when I read my
actual writing back it sounds like I
talk and I abuse and mutilate this
language on purpose like I enjoy the
organic nature of English because it's a
growing language and I I like to verb my
nouns and now my verbs and use
adjectives and adverbs interchangeably
like Urban nouns bars but I I think it's
uh it's more fun to use language in a
fluid way and I think that's um not as
conducive in the written form and also
the reason I stopped acting is I didn't
feel good about other people's language
in my mouth and even worse when I hear
other people use my language it sounds
weird so I think if I wrote it would be
very odd for another person to try to
articulate in the way that I wield
language but as stories go I do think I
could bring a lot to Marvel as far as
shaping things ah yes
it's quite duplicitous of you quite Zeal
questions
[Laughter]
the coin the koi of it all yes yes sorry
for being sincere for a moment sorry no
we don't do that not here
only when we're watching movie trailers
don't ask that question Gabriel we're
gonna get a wormhole here
um thank you for the Super Chat the film
was just average Majors was the best
part but seems like he elevated the
character than the scripted it's hey
John question do you think It suffers
from the same issue as Iron Man 2 in Age
of Ultron where it just felt like set up
uh kind of up until the end where the
setup is a bit confusing other than the
idea that more kangs will come in some
fashion yeah sure you know like I
actually forgive it certain things
because it is just the beginning and
it's just here to say this is the big
bad we're gonna have to deal with moving
forward so it is like in a way its own
contained innocuous Adventure that just
happens to be setting up a very uh
significant figure but uh you know I say
I can't give it that forgetting
forgiveness because I'm like it's five
it's the fifth beginning and I think
they ought to be stronger by this point
but someone did have a good point in the
chat which uh was that he he got sucked
into the corner that sent him to the the
Beyond where he's going to come back as
Beyond her King I like that theory it
sounds free solid yeah it's a good
theory I got a little bit of a g fuel on
my mouse here so that's why it's like
glitching a little bit uh Flying
Squirrels 83 thank you so much I wish
people would discuss how wasp displayed
so little of her own agency or got an
arc in a movie called Ant-Man and the
wasp
yeah boo
um I'll be there in 20 seconds
I I agree I must answer to my wife she's
being called she is my rivona rensslayer
go I like the idea that she was in the
chat we didn't see it now she's doing it
manually uh I agree with this statement
and that's also why uh oh this is our
one a flying squirrel you're honored
with 20 minutes of this uh oh what'd I
miss what happened oh uh I I agree I
think that's why I wanted the Ant-Man of
the WASP to be uh Hank and Janet because
I think Janet had a lot more to do like
I feel like wasp in this film was Janet
Van Dyne which is the comic books
original wasp so I think the ending that
I had with it being Ant-Man and the
Wallace quantumia about Hank and Janet
would have allowed for this it also is
kind of strange that um she got that
ending moment after a movie of like she
only saved the day like she swooped in
and grabbed him probability she saved
him at the very end but like we didn't
get to spend a lot of time with her
that's why I would have had Hank kind of
off on his own C plot and then let them
be back and forth because I did feel
like wasp was missing much like she was
in the first film
oh hello there
there's a dog
oh my here's the situation in reality
people if we see an animal in pain we
gotta go help it so there was a dog
outside our home and it looks really
frail and sick and it's clearly alone
and we don't know who it belongs to
so we're gonna try to help can you close
that door and keep the dog in here this
dog is struggling right now so I'm gonna
step out from this stream for just like
five minutes and go hit up some
neighbors because right now neighbors
have no idea who this very ill dog
belongs to yeah it's shaking it's
definitely sick
um his nose is doing and he's thirsty so
we're gonna get him some water first
there he is right here you can see he's
scared and alone
[Music]
the wife and I are massive animal lovers
he's like a little Pixar and he's
definitely his tongue is out which is a
bad sign
this dog uh suffer right now yeah yeah
don't touch that too probably
um but we're gonna get him some water
but he has to stay in here because we
got four cats right I don't want to get
attacked so we're gonna do like this
stream just got a little more exciting
for her
it's a very real guy real moment right
now
and uh John yeah let's assume the old
positions here sure yeah yeah uh the
WASP I I want him to feel comfortable
and I might get a little sick the hole
in him I just worry about like
whatever's going on yeah yeah so
um yeah I'm gonna be right back by all
means
um yeah the the WASP thing is
I don't know I mean like yes you're
taken aback by the fact that she is such
a slight character and I feel like the
most cathartic moment that hope gets is
that little moment at the end where they
tell each other that they love each
other I thought that was nice uh but
yeah
in one breath with an ant family I can
understand how in certain installments
certain people are more prominent
certain people are less prominent that's
actually kind of fine with me I do think
the way the movie presents hope though
you just feel like scenes were taken out
and there's not really like a
reconciliation with Janet in a cathartic
or or I feel like her and Janet
reconciling in some kind of meaningful
way after all of this and after hope
being the one who's like Mom open up I
feel like that would have been good but
but her not being like
her not being like a huge Focus
isn't that big of a bummer but it would
be nice to see her have an actual sense
of agency or like prominence even though
she isn't getting the Lion's Share of
the moments or screen time and the
Ant-Man and the WASP being two sets of
people I feel like was almost set up
like I really like Scott's respect for
Hank that they directly called out I
really like the the two Janet Hope
moments that we got but like that could
have been a lot deeper for me uh ever
Brown in the chat wants to know and I
asked my friend this directly after
talking to them last night uh y'all
think Kang uh slept with Janet I think
they definitely got it 100 100 dead at
some point she saw his Nathaniel
Richards a few times
I definitely think he conquered and uh
there were some moments in that Quantum
realm that were Quantum Mania between
the sheets and I'm very excited for her
because I feel like Jonathan Majors
knows what he's doing I feel like there
was a menajah Quantum going on I also
think there's a lot of kangs is it even
a orgy if they're all the same person
that's the question are you like a
little Italian Greenhouse fascinating
creature you are I've I've never seen a
dog quite like this yeah his face is
like a Pixar character fascinated that
you wound up oh and he can stand on his
hind legs dude he's like a greyhound
Mouse
he's also a little blind you're good how
old are you Michael Michael Loco as we
as we dip in and out he's like well
you're throwing his hind legs like a
human for a second yeah he wanted to
read the chat he'd been like trying to
hang out he's just fascinated he's here
to talk about it he's getting calmer
yeah he's immediately not as shaky he
just keeps like bumping into I don't
think he can see so good he's coming to
check us out and stuff like that he's
got some little tumors or or cysts and
stuff yeah he's definitely a Vibe hey
buddy hey buddy you want to see Uncle
koi yeah he definitely smells Spidey cat
Michael Loco thank you for jumping in
for contributing to the chat uh maybe
right Kang like Light Yagami from Death
Note
I feel like any time you say maybe write
somebody like Light Yagami from Death
Note you're asking for like
a huge task of uh of uh maybe makes
citizenry sure sure citizen Kang let's
do it
but where he actually just runs a
newspaper uh very exciting Multiverse
he's bored with Progressive steps skips
to the end and is full of himself
thinking he will win sure I mean yeah
absolutely like like I think that's a
good call lights
then though you need everyone else to be
else
problem maybe I don't know
Dynasty if you have it as a singular
film like if you I'd love the idea of of
Kang doing all of that like we talked
about the setup and then at the end they
have to undermine it like that that
could work for a for a movie to do and
then follow it up but yeah yeah I like I
like Kang as Light Yagami I like that at
least idea
uh Dan v900 but even that even Death
Note had a bit of trouble keeping that
consistent and paying that all the way
off six neighbors later are you fine you
find who the dog it was yeah oh damn
this is just a really old dog but the
neighbor everything yeah I asked the
neighbor who showed a photo and the
neighbor was like oh I know who the dog
belongs to oh amazing oh boy Greg's an
Avenger there's a lot of running
anyway how's the stream you guys telling
the same questions
we've done a couple questions
uh do you think that Janet and Kang uh
did it when they were down there in the
quantum realm stranded together yeah
it's definitely a thousand percent why
wouldn't she has needs she said so who
wouldn't do king as Jonathan ready for
it see the way he moves and he's
fighting Ant-Man of course he would he
moved so fast maybe rapid speed after
getting that old ass Hank Pym it was
like grouchy it's true even when he was
young he was just like Moody just always
grumpy you know he's a runner there's a
death to Jonathan Major's eyes that no
one can run I'll catch it
yeah it was a bit fast I'm very
impressed he did good work
saving
animals always take the chance yeah
we're on to Envy okay yeah guys damn
v900 listen everyone I got a question
for you I just can't really talk about
it I got this baby you're so you're so
money by Cassie calling Hank Grandpa
where they had no time to get clothes
one is everything fine babe
all right
um
as a child and figuring out Hank wasn't
like himself either
you're right that is a great point when
would they have bonded in that one year
after she was recast I totally forgot
there's a lot of weird stuff that
happens off screen and then doesn't
quite check out with the timeline I mean
it's a good thing the villain doesn't
have anything to do with time where they
can make that useful
I see what you did
please coin I wonder if we get to meet
Linda in the next movie J Coby podoc hey
coitus what you said
Modoc gave me George Lopez and Sharkboy
and Lava Girl Vibe put respect to that
Robert Rodriguez trilogy's name yeah is
it a Trilogy now I know they made a
second one
this is
its own movie yeah and then they made
the follow-up place four Spy Kids movies
one Shark Boy two Sharkboy and Lava
Girls so there's five the first ones
with Taylor Lautner yes yeah so there's
five films in the Spy Kids Saga
a Trilogy of Spy Kids and true Sharkboy
Lava Girl correct but they're not Spy
Kids movies no there's four Spy Kids
movies Oh I thought it was all connected
I was young no they just looked the same
yeah okay I was just young and I I just
saw them when I was a child they have
the Robert Rodriguez green screen family
movie aesthetic yeah so I thought it was
one okay Omni Bray
went to see quantumania Thursday
Amity you guys liked it better when I
wasn't here admit it did they say it is
that what they said the stream that's
all we talked about there were a bunch
of super chats that were just like oh
God you guys sent a dog in here together
we have a release the hounds button
we'll get rid of Greg for six to seven
minutes and then we can go as off-road
as we want we're gonna talk about Majors
bone and fight for such a frail dog that
was insane that dog came in looking like
the end of Santa's little helper's life
yeah I was very worried for Sam's Little
Helper I was like what is happening uh
yeah thank God for the missus
she makes a lot of sarcastic cracks in
the chat she's one of the Swedish she
might be mean to me and me and John but
she is not mean to animals no
true if we were animals we should be
coming yeah and ask her to treat you
like your animals that's all we ask I
hear the way she talks to those cats man
I I would be so encouraged all the time
so motivated the villain of Guardians
could help that happen uh
went to see quantumania Thursday and was
honestly satisfied
like how King said Shannon thank you do
you think this movie sets up King as a
big bad Bell and will villain well he's
great but I'm split uh I'm a little
split too I this is the one time with
with Facebook I'm like I'm gonna wait to
see how they handle some care I'm not
100 confident but you know the
introduction of King was in he who it
might just depend on what property he's
in or what or what project he's under
because Thanos it's like you get you get
like little bits here and there like
guardians or something like little Omni
teases it's kind of a bold move to be
like he's gonna be the main villain
instead of just having to be a tease you
know minus undercutting from certain
plot elements I think it does a good job
of establishing his presence I think he
does a good job of showcasing him as a
performer I think Jonathan Majors gets
Kang so I think that gives me confidence
and I feel like Christian Bale doesn't
get enough credit for doing a good job
as Gore he's horrific when he's on
screen
every time he wasn't God butchering but
people like it's funny because
they give they don't give Gora they
don't give Gore the god butcher a pass
but people give this a lot of a big pass
because of how great Jonathan Majors is
oh that is interesting because the
performances are both amazing yeah but I
think that we had more screen time with
major people like they ruined God
butcher it's because he it probably
doesn't help but he's called God
[Music]
is kids not with a y That's okay uh what
if the reason we have not seen Reed is
because 616 Reed is the direct ancestor
of he who remains and the kings are
currently hunting him in F4 I don't
think it was [__] enough about Reed
Richards enough to find him do they well
and they would have to find him in the
60s right and they confirmed the movies
in the 60s I think this is all I think
there's one thing we've learned by
getting into phase five is we have a lot
of theories that sound way cooler than
what often the movies end up doing
themselves so when they deliver
what they have to reserve that that's
why like the ending of end game is so
powerful because you're like this is
ever there I ever got a [__] water
well I know why home is so powerful
because we're like they actually did
that [__]
that's but a lot of the time I think we
we often set ourselves up it's really
not trailers that are the problem it's
us it's the theater I think where we get
a little carried away yeah a few things
a few things Inspire such a constant and
and such a comprehensive yes Theory
cycle yeah and then when scrutiny and
then when they have a couple of movies
that end up doing it then we're like the
bars changed the bars change
our expectation only increases now this
is an interesting point no cap Kang
doesn't have access to the most powerful
weapon in this movie which is time uh
because the quantum realm does exist
outside of space and time so
that's a fair point actually but that's
why it's hard to introduce Kang in a way
that has him de-powered because you the
movie should yes affect phase five but
the movie itself should work like the
the good thing about phase one through
three is most the films eighty percent
of the films worked as their own thing
as well as setup the reason Iron Man 2
doesn't work is it felt too set up but
like I feel like they didn't learn that
lesson in the direction they needed to
and I feel like that's why they're
course correcting but it should also
work as its own thing in addition to
being like wow it's crazy how connected
it was and my concern now is they're
trying to appeal too much to every they
have to build everyday audiences but
they need to also appeal to the people
that had the in-game experience the
people that know the lore and I feel
like it needs to be both for the people
screaming on Reddit and the people that
are like oh I'm just gonna watch this
movie as and I feel like Ant-Man only
appealed to that oh I'm just gonna go
watch this movie audience that's
something I've noticed talking to to
multiple people is that the people who
aren't who check into the MCU sometimes
have been enjoying things I think a lot
more uh lately yeah than people I talk
to who are up on everything and really
focused on the overarching and hey it
made 120 million dollars it's tracking
do do really well and I'm really happy
for the artists and the creators but I
do think there's a thing where they
cared more about this side of focus more
before and that might go back but it
might not yeah yeah
Ganon fish thoughts on the small
characters like web Modoc and Bill
Murray to the rejects I appreciate all
y'all have done for us comic book nerds
I appreciate John and Coy more
then the mirror you know what I mean
yeah myself yeah yeah I haven't even
looked at myself today that's how much
Irish feature you guys have been looking
at you I know I know it's weird I'm
learning I think he's looking into our
pupils so he can see himself
does my does the Reflection In My Eyes
reflect the way I also see you is it how
you see me that I see myself yeah
exactly I like that I like veb is holes
guy yes yes I like I like veb that's the
small chin yeah he was the one I really
um he was the most enjoyable I didn't a
lot of people thought that was like such
a easy plot narrative with the whole
like they get to hear people and I'm
like I loved it I'm like [__] it no
that's perfect that's some Doctor Who
[__] that's fine I am just I would have
been more bothered if everyone's
speaking English because that would have
been then I would have been like why is
everyone speaking English down here
that's the thing in Star Wars that
happens shouts out to Chidi from the
good place too I thought he did a good
job um but Bill Murray uh it's
interesting that they would have Bill
Murray like I find the thing that I
found interesting is that they have he
was kind of funny at first but I thought
Bill Murray overall did a good job in
that scene when he transitions yeah he
doesn't look like he's laughing at the
material it looks like he took it
seriously and he made the situation feel
more realized in my opinion like he
shows up Charming that aristocat
Personality yeah and then when he takes
that switch where he's clearly bothered
by Janet and he had to succumb to Kang
and give into this I bought it I thought
he did a good job it doesn't for some
reason it doesn't leave an impression at
the same time though that's the weird
part because no one's talking about it
and like no one talks about it yeah how
late did it take for Bill Murray to get
brought up in the Stream like yeah no
one really talks about it and uh I think
it's cool that they had Russell Crowe a
very serious actor show up to do
something funny and then they have Bill
Murray you have to do something serious
sure yeah I thought everybody in the
cast did a good job no matter how slight
like like uh Torah or whatever the
warrior woman is like she is written so
wrote but I liked her presence the guy
who could read minds I thought he did a
great job uh I forget the actor's name
William Jackson Harper I thought they're
going to make that woman ravona for a
second yeah like a different version of
her yeah um
Kennedy
um
I should have gave me that comic Greg it
ruined your experience no it did I
shouldn't I shouldn't resourced to her
uh but don't read comments so Recon from
the real reason I'm about I bet at the
end of the day this movie makes more
than Thor love and thunder worldwide I'd
expect it to I think it'll be more
agreeable it's the start of phase five
and it
I don't know I think it's more than Thor
in less than uh Doctor Strange because
doctor exchange made a lot of money I
find cinema scores more reliable on
audience reception than than Rotten
Tomatoes percentages both audience and
critic for me yeah no no I'm talking
about the audience score on Rotten
Tomatoes yeah I find a way I find a
Cinema score more reliable of how an
audience generally feels because I feel
like you people don't Bard people don't
take to cinema score to bomb things as
much I don't think yeah you don't get
like questioned and then like have this
crazy whereas I feel like rotten
tomatoes I feel like people don't
understand what Rotten Tomatoes is and
therefore they abuse it in both
directions they didn't understand that
Rotten Tomatoes is the critics it's a
council it's a committee where everyone
gets together and they all vote
unanimously of how we all feel about it
before they put out a percentage and
they yell and that's why people say
don't listen to critics because it's a
hive mind essentially where everyone's
in it they're not actual real fans
they're just people who um they they are
a jury of credit scene yeah
how loud
that's why you know when in doubt just
go don't listen to critics because
apparently they're not real people
they've never been human
there's a lot there's a lot of problem
about that yeah
um I think it's a weird Fail-Safe to say
that well it's like every written review
gets boiled down to a number and then
those numbers all get averaged out and
that becomes the score and I feel like
pass fail that is colorized it's
literally like colorizing a historic
photo you've got a black and white photo
that you put color over it of course
it's not going to be the actual
quantifiable image just like looking at
a 70 that doesn't mean 70 it means 70
out of blank number of critics pass or
failed it if a hundred percent of people
gave it a 2.5 it would fail but if 100
people gave it a three it would be a
hundred percent that's not this thing
and you can look through movies that
have a high percentage but see that all
the capsules are like it's okay you know
like it's a three out of five which is
technically fresh my favorite part of
the audience score site on Rotten
Tomatoes is that people are like don't
listen to critics here's my home
you understand you are if you watched a
bunch of movies and are about to give an
opinion congratulations you've met all
the requirements
anyone who does YouTube videos
and I would gladly say this to Christian
harloff's face I hope you're watching
buddy anyone who said that they don't
that they're like I don't I'm not a
Critic I'm like but you review movies
regularly and they're monetized videos
and you gain an audience from it so you
might not call yourself a critic but you
fall under the umbrella and same thing
with us I don't even I don't like the
word influencer
I still fall under that umbrella all
right I know it's one of my categories
even though I don't like to identify as
that so yeah I think there's a lot more
of these people who are like I think if
you're on YouTube especially you're like
don't listen to critics I'm like but
you're a Critic you're technically part
of that realm yeah technically part of
it just doesn't make sense to say that
didn't find the critics that you like
and understand when people are
approaching something from a filmmaking
Cinema perspective versus a lore uh like
uh yeah Focus what point are we at in
the streams because I gotta clip out
that part about Christian Harlow
well I gotta delete it I don't want I
gotta I gotta make sure he doesn't get
offended oh yeah yeah
um I mean you guys doing a show tomorrow
sure oh [__] that's right damn it uh oh
did I just plug for you I hope he
doesn't bring it up on stage oh he's
gonna bring it up on the stage and our
next topic today
um deviant production do you guys
remember wait wait wait wait didn't
shout someone out uh someone with an
Asian name okay if I say shout out thank
you for the heart means a lot uh it's a
cool symbol whatever their name is
deviant production
thank you do you remember Janet's power
she got from spending so much time in
the quantum realm oh my God I should
have re-watched Quantum 100 and the WASP
she had powers didn't she have some
Powers uh there's like a residual I've
only seen it once there's not a lot of
continuity for men
yeah because they're also there's the
whole Quantum tunnel thing in the post
credits and all that stuff I totally
forgot about that that's a great that's
a really great point I didn't put that
together the thing I didn't re-watch
that movie I might have liked it
[Laughter]
[Music]
took a third time then you found your
love for it in a way j golby p
people pushing the whole MCU declining
in quality or starting to get annoying I
want them to improve but that's not to
say we haven't put on any Great Stuff
Plus doesn't like act like the infinity
Saga was consistent agree I agree I mean
I loved black panther were coming
forever and that was the last movie yeah
so I I really loved it no and I think
there's some of my favorite hits of the
MCU total had phase four in them but the
thing is some of the most
like
the ones that did not really leave an
impression where I just kind of stopped
thinking about it really quick a lot of
that was phase four too I think the
highest highs were in earlier phases but
the lowest lows were in this phase more
consistently so it overall feels more
negative yeah and they have an
interesting and phase four is the first
one would show so the journey with it is
interesting because they could have
something like Hawkeye where I was like
ah first episode five but they started
getting really good and intriguing and
then I really thought they dropped the
ball in the final episode like really
did and that's the impression that's the
feeling I'm left with is how they
dropped the ball it's that and the rant
when you start and end something it's
like what we joked about earlier with
debate like that is also how I feel
about like Moon Knight I loved Moon
Knight until I didn't and then I liked
it but I don't think about it a lot yeah
exactly uh and you know let's not forget
Man One Division was the start of this
oh one division was the first MCU
property I think where everywhere I went
we were all just talking about one of
them right you know everything what's
going to happen next that you liked
Marvel or not TV yeah talking about one
you were at Chipotle and the person
making you that burrito bowl what do you
think is gonna happen do you think
mutants are coming
water brown rice
what do you think it's Mephisto it's
just growing pains and and the fact that
we're like 30 odd movies into this like
I feel like they just have been
struggling lately to find the synthesis
of their sweet spot again like I feel
like you can see all the faculties that
make an MCU what it is in most of these
properties and it's just the levels are
skewed more jaggedly right now to me I
also think we want more from them
because we've seen what they can
accomplish and that's not it's not
necessarily Fair because it's new teams
new expectations new writers we look at
this giant 30 film Saga as one thing
which it is but it's also not their
individual pieces make up that puzzle so
it's really hard to even quantify but I
also want that bar to be met and
therefore I'm having a hard time with
Ant-Man not being a hard swallow comic
books are up and down too very much
very much hamsa Omar we gotcha love the
channel especially koi Jesus what does
that say about my ego well kojex quick
shouts out to Gom films in the chat too
hey George what's going on buddy he has
a hilarious Ben Affleck AI video oh my
God it's so fun
um go watch it guys the scene of the
possibility realm it was established the
other Ant-Man won't re weren't real so
how did they physically help him
I don't know it doesn't matter it was
cool
theoretical I think yeah I thought they
were real like they were they were the
concept of what alternate reality he
could do like the like if I do this
versus this that would be another me but
that would be tangible in that in that
realm yeah it's like every reaction
becomes
it's like distilling the Multiverse down
into one room where every possibility
just comes out and so like in that you
know again space between space and time
you can mumbo jumbo it in a way where I
wasn't too distracted I was more
distracted and I enjoyed it but I was
more distracted by like why is there
only one Scott who is not an Ant-Man
Garb I like right I like Baskin Robbins
guy I love it but also why is he the
only one you know I think they say we
can't Define what a good Marvel film is
oh yeah I saw that well I think a good
Marvel film is when it has a good
three-act structure and there's a good
character Journey
a little bit of you know set up for the
future of phases sure uh but a good
Marvel film like John just said is just
a good film it's pretty plain and simple
I'll take a good film over big
interconnectivity any day set up payoff
steam system
exploring themes you know
basic [__]
is good that has Marvel characters in it
because it's easy to make something fun
the first two Ant-Man movies are a great
example and I get that this the first
two ant-mans and like The Avengers or
Infinity warning okay those are great
examples of how you can do either very
serious or very light and still flesh
them out you know true yeah I think we
know Alex our biggest Super Chat of the
day all the buttons
[Music]
King should be the only person capable
of using his own technology Cassie Lang
manipulated his technology plot hole
fair enough I thought Cassie was way too
good at everything in this her only
struggle was she has to get the jump tap
thing down that's the only struggle she
has I feel like they yeah they nerfed
her arcs and and the opportunity for
yeah conflict I was very vexed when I
was watching the movie and went oh so
this is why they didn't advertise
strange world that Jake Jill and whole
movie because they made it an Ant-Man
movie and then I was also a vexed and I
was like oh this is why Andor is okay
because the third Act is they used and
door sets like this was literally like
what Cassie did they just did nandor and
strange world and I was like I've seen
these so like I was I was bothered when
she took over Kang's
um hologram and a hologram the
projection of himself yeah the trans
yeah yeah yeah that bothered me his
password because it's just
it's just like how what she just shove
like I mean it just happens off screen
and it's just convenient because I think
you went to the bathroom briefly the
first time I did and then you came back
you were so quick he came back and she
was on the screen and I was like uh yeah
she took over the thing he was talking
to uh because she's good
how'd that happen and Greg I could have
it off screen I don't know I think they
pass it off as gentura is the one who
actually manipulates the machine and
then she's like Cassie say something you
know I gotta fight these dudes but even
so they never really show you that would
I really took it as she I thought Cassie
did it so that way gentura could go and
make the speech but she was like no
you'd make the speech because why would
Cassie be fighting off goons and guards
no she doesn't I'm just saying I think
hacked the thing and is like I gotta go
fight these dudes now you need to talk
to them you know like I'm not gonna talk
to them you know either way either way
it still does not address how it was
possible what the technology is why from
here remotely to where Kang is it still
worked and why he wouldn't just be able
to usurp that yeah
that is more like what you see on like
amusement park rides sure also like
that's I mean to go immediately back to
dude saying we don't know a good Marvel
film every movie has plot holes every
movie has continuity issues every movie
has things that don't always line up
like movies are so many moving Parts but
stuff like this where it impacts like
this many things that's what makes it
lesser like there's no one good kind of
Marvel movie because they're all
blending genres and trying to do
slightly different things so again a
good Marvel movie is just a good version
of whatever they're attempting to do but
if you're
man one is a good heist comedy then
that's a good Marvel movie because it's
doing its thing right yeah Roger thank
you for such a generous Super Chat Roger
Reyes
everyone expects so much in these movies
nowadays nobody knows what Marvel has
planned but the writing needs
Improvement this is only the beginning
yeah that's the that's the main thing
that I think ebony leopard
thank you for being here in the soup in
the Stream that's what I'm going to say
uh everything we said is nitpicky not
valid criticisms whatsoever is it a
broad spectrum
problems the less you're enjoying
something the more you will nitpick but
I feel like we have addressed some
reasonable ideas here I think nitpicks
stand out more when you already have
bigger problems yeah when something's
already not working then everything
everything just becomes a big file so
yeah so critics could do a better job of
factoring out what doesn't really matter
to the criticism but but I mean yeah I
think that is the main thing is that you
would need yeah oh my God we got to show
this chat I think it's very funny just
whatever grammar's that bad it makes me
laugh because I don't use grammar well
but that's just fine um nobody knows
that Marvel has planned I yeah that is
the thing is that we don't really know
what Marvel has plan and I don't really
care about that it I do care that
there's their Standalone installments
are
actually you know good like great like
that's what matters most to keep you
can't just keep tuning in things that
are just fine sorry ebony leopard we
only get one comment at a time so also
like what's happening he said only point
out was that he said nitpicky but that's
all we saw was him saying anyway uh
everything can't be a trailer for the
next thing and like yeah Iron Man it can
have like a little thing but it
shouldn't be the main thing like Iron
Man was great without anything else yeah
and end game Winter Soldier is
Incredible without ever having seen
First Avenger or Civil War that is the
standard for me
like no way home is great even if you've
never I brought someone to the premiere
that had never seen a Toby or Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man film which I didn't
think was possible but she loved it only
knowing two Tom Holland movies that's a
good movie yeah and that's a movie that
has a lot of silly circumstances that
tie it together but it prioritizes the
right aspects to make it you know as
impactful as it is so I think I would
argue that as the nuts and bolts of no
way home are very uh you know flying by
the seat of your pants but I think when
you like something and then people don't
like if you if you like something and
then when people you're listening to
someone who doesn't like something
saying someone's being nitpicky instead
of acknowledging everything that we did
say is kind of a this is weak excuse
it's been hours long this is like hours
of stuff yeah Johnny each following
movies should have
variants
each following movie should have hero
variants I don't know if each following
movies
ebony leopard I'm going to stop you
right there you see what you're doing
buddy you're nitpicking one thing we
said you're being nitpicky over one
thing so and the points
what you're saying about nitpicking
that's not yours in the movie literally
zeroing in on one out of a hundred
things we said so your whole thing is
completely invalid now gosh
each following movie should have hero
bearings you just set yourself up to me
having fun this should just be fun no no
fun anymore you see what happens no
that's fun anymore I like the phone
chat the second time
saving a dog and now he's the one I
don't want to deal with this today it's
been a a long week
this guy's been too nice
he's following moves should have hero
Barons fine let it happen everything's
great so actually I don't understand
this question is he saying that it's not
a question it's a statement of a request
that he wants for the future of Marvel
every one of them yeah yeah so every
villain is a hero every one of them I
don't know just there should be
multiversal variants of every hero
moving forward in each installment yes
season two might be that sure
2021 thank you for the Super Chat how
quickly do you guys think Marvel can
course correct I don't know quick maybe
quicker clearly they're capable of
greatness look at the infinity Saga I
know it was amazing I keep hearing of
these delays but if writers aren't good
does more time help I mean I think they
hire good writers but usually you do
need more time to flesh stuff out
sometimes the greatest screenplays take
years to flesh out I I I'm very I have
come to a place where I uh
very Ginger about how I how hard I rest
on my complaints not with scripts but
with the writers of the scripts it's
like this guy Jeff loveness who wrote
this yeah I'm like this to me doesn't
reflect great on your script writing for
something like this however I am aware
that with this machine I have seen
writers I trust turn in something that
feels a lot more generic than I thought
it should knowing their other works so I
feel like the machine is so big that I
think sometimes it will slight the
writer true and uh and so yeah I tend to
keep that criticism kind of
software I didn't even mention something
really quick um because of the time
right now and I would like to wrap this
up by 2 30.
okay
or close oh yeah I'm going to close down
the the super we're going to read the
rep we will go through the rest of the
super chats and we got some streamlabs
too that I want to make sure we get to
uh but yeah I would like to end by a
certain time today because because I
Do's got so little bit more other things
to edit today and I'm gonna wave the
white bag we haven't seen everything you
have had to say this is a big old
conversation it's all love baby it's all
love let's bury that hatchet do we just
I block him
I will say uh time I believe in
censorship
we're gonna talk about nitpicky [__]
like people are gonna it's fine it's all
I think we're too focused on him now and
now we need to we need to just we need
to just move on and accept what's the
next question
as I go to P I want to acknowledge that
each of us has a different threshold
where I love that psychologically I
would assume that I'd get mad first and
calm down and that Greg would build to a
boil and that John would have mid like
high lows and that's exactly what
happened in the last two hours I think
it's very funny like our personalities
are exactly this live stream
ing
that is a necessary part of any
screenplay now you're a likable
character completely cool
um anyway
oh [__] just John and I oh man now what
just John uh now it's like every day
what do we do
um
shout out awkward jokes do you have a
Linda in your life John do I have a
limited in my life uh she ain't you baby
nicely done
that's that's that's how that goes
oh oh my God we gotta get to that koi
question so he's not here to defend
himself Jenny L I definitely want to say
any toy complaints get them in right now
so that way we can't defend himself cool
it'll be amazing coin planes new segment
coin plates
um Ash Chase thanks for being here King
should have killed someone or showed
Scott dying or other Avengers 2 show how
big a threat King really is all he had
to do was break Cassie's arm or break
Cassie's arm or I I mean it would have
been cool if he killed off Ant-Man I
think it would have worked and then it
would get that actually could have given
him an arc because he would have
sacrificed like see Cassie and these
nuts was the last version
bitterness and trying to prove a point
take my bitter blame with you and make
that your core wound for the rest of
this franchise your fault I'm dead now
Cassie bye like art uh Paul M ah damn it
I was trying to get some white
complaints in here coin planes coin
planes get your coin planes Johnny you
get a standing break and get a standing
break in your crotch will be blocked by
this by the Super Chat look look at my
crutch it's funny my my legs are
actually 12 bigger to my body ratio than
the rest of me I just got a Nexus can
done so my uh my all my proportions are
weird because I like the gym too much
and I'm five nine but uh my arms just
look big in the shirt which I appreciate
it's okay that's right he's got small
arms in real life uh
discussion would you be more excited for
a pain and read Star Wars or Star Trek
movie or neither seems like he wants to
do sci-fi I really enjoyed his episode
of the Mandalorian season two it's the
one where they land that's a coin plate
it's the one where they land in the uh
this ice place and there's like spider
bug stingy oh yeah that's right that was
his yeah the thing uh I thought he did a
great job there and really captured the
horror and still that like ethereal
Wonder as well so I would like to see
him do a Star Wars movie or just direct
another episode of the Mandalorian it
doesn't matter what I just scratch
myself with my middle fingers
that I love and I haven't talked about
it at all anywhere yet uh I think Peyton
Reed really wanted to make a Quantum
realm slash Phantom Zone Fantastic Four
movie and when they hired John Watts to
make Fantastic Four Kevin feige was like
What if we let the third Ant-Man movie
be your Fantastic Four movie and a big
complaint I had was this felt like if
the Fantastic Four was fighting Kang in
this universe he would have worked for
the physics of their decisions more but
this became his Fantastic Four I don't
think this movie speaks incredibly
directly to Peyton Reed's abilities and
his voice as a director especially as
compared to the previous two Ant-Man
movies but I would be interested to see
him do I would sooner say Star Wars and
Star Trek but really with those movies
could be anybody's guess
Thief
hi koi
can you explain the time in Quantum
realm the flow of time is the same it's
just at which point of time of the time
of the outside world you come out so
conceptually time being relative the
bigger uh you get from your Source kind
of like Interstellar the the further you
are from do you need a paper to yeah
but uh but like so the further you are
from your sense of time the greater
disparate distance so arguably if they
go deeper than they've ever been because
there's a single line of dialogue
Michelle Pfeiffer says that you didn't
look deep enough to see the living
creatures right you had to look further
and that's kind of what they they write
over all the plot holes of the things
we've described with like those tie-ins
so it theoretically should be more time
because they're further through that
reality but since it's Quantum and it's
out of time and space which is another
line of dialogue they gave conceptually
it would be parallel to time if you're
out of time and space the distance from
your original reality shouldn't be
affected but they also implied that it
was further so technically they should
have been
further from their time more time should
have passed but they kind of allowed
that to not have time passed because
they were out of time it seems like they
let time pass for the ant family in real
time and the ants go to the place where
time dilation happens right that makes a
lot of sense like I like the senses that
everyone's saying sub subatomic yeah oh
my God guys are so smart Geniuses over
here you guys should teach a science
class Mike K what up reject Nation thank
you just got back from round two of the
movie loved it just as much as the first
time hell yeah wait till you watch it a
third time my question is about Loki
season two how much will we see Jonathan
Majors he's going to be there the whole
time it's does seem like he will be a
through line more so than before I don't
be on the search for him they're going
to be hunting for him yeah I mean I
don't expect them to completely ditch
the episodic nature of the show and not
do unrelated or things kind of
tangentially related in different times
and places but I feel like yeah Kang
will be a much more it will be a Serial
through line yeah yeah I think it'll be
a very big part of it and then they kill
him off and then they got a new threat
to deal with and that's when they see
Sylvie go to McDonald's or whatever that
photo I am so faster
and Loki meal the cardigan offset meals
I will get a Happy Meal if there's Loki
toys oh yeah
ooh what if King is actually working
with some probabilities
oh that's fun I like that oh and it's
like solving the problem I can talk by
Consulting his probabilities I like that
a lot it's actually cool that would be
neat yeah I watch a whole movie out of
that that's what I want out of Marvel
uh raccoon shampoo thanks for being here
buddy good to see you Broccoli Guy
lovely guy
hilarious appreciate the Super Chat
D Murdock koi you shill you seem more
positive on a Harley oh I actually
really wanted to address this there was
a ton of people in the chat
um I think that all movies should be
seen and celebrated if they're even half
good so all my non-spoilers were
positive because I wanted [__] to go
see the movie so like yeah I was more
positive in my non-spoiler review and
then the spoiler review I did with
harloff is going to be a little bit more
negative because I I want people to
support Marvel I want people to go see
the first two acts of this I think it's
worth seeing but if I came out the gate
as negative as I feel about the film
people wouldn't get to experience those
first two acts like I and genuinely
opinion and yeah literally I don't want
to be a critic that I don't like people
blindly following anyone and I do feel
like we live in an age where people go
like well if koi doesn't like it then
it's not worth seeing because I'm be
positive about everything so I leaned
very positive because I didn't want the
like well this is the first time he's
negative it's got to be really bad
because of how people like black and
white things the world is grayscale so I
was like I'll lean into my positive side
of the grayscale in the non-spoiler I'll
lean more aggressively I've been almost
only negative about this film I still
gave it like a 6.4 I've talked about
very few of my positives because that's
in my non-spoiler I think people need to
see short media rating that's where I'm
at
6.4259 I know exactly where it is also I
love Jimmy freckles comment be insulted
I've I've had too many experiences
require recommend something and then I
watch and I'm like that sucked why'd I
listen to him then I listen to a spoiler
talk and I'm like oh he actually that's
how he feels why I don't so that's the
path also most my flaws worth of third
act so inherently they're spoilers I
think that's an issue
hi Mom thanks for joining us
I said it like two minutes oh Liam
Murphy Loki season two will be huge in
determining King's threat oh yeah I want
Hank Pym to go after him just because he
banged Janet you know it happened he
just becomes a jealous abusive husband
she's gonna do it with Bill Murray why
wouldn't she do it
for sure legit saved her life come on
now come on you've seen those pictures
and uh like what the Ebony magazine
shoot was incredible he's got the
bodybuilder movie coming out that was
the original magazine oh my God damn
magazine dreams he looks incredible in
that man like good God that should have
been his suit that should be one of the
king variants
he's the only one who's not concerned
with anything about time or conquering
that's so true he just wants the
Fountain of you so he can keep on doing
magazine covers Amen to that sister the
I laughed at this film more than I did
in Thor three I even love the post
credit scene anyone think like Hank was
gonna die I rated 8.5 out of 10. once I
realized that uh Michael Douglas was
just kind of casually walking through a
green screen through this most of this
room I'm like I don't think he's gonna
die and then I feel like him saying he
would only return if he does die in the
next one is usually an indicator that an
actor was indeed over the experience
while they were making the film oh 100
so and it's totally and I didn't know
that until after I watched the movie and
already well put out my opinion I was
like yeah no it shows on screen dude
like you clearly did not want to do this
movie Hank be chilling and it's not
consistent with the previous one
although I I do personally in isolation
enjoy chilling uh swashbuckler who just
shows up in his robes and he's like I
like games
up for the silliness but yeah it doesn't
work in tandem as well Man comic fan
have you ever been asked to do the
trailer movie breakdowns for new rock
stars koi uh tell Eric Voss to go to
hell yeah I think Eric like I'm really
good at certain things and Eric Voss is
really good at certain things and I
think he's like so good at breakdowns
and stuff I uh I watch trailers I think
differently and I think if they want me
to I I could like look at a thing that
way but I inherently don't go like that
visual like I don't I don't like I feel
like Eric is like this incredible
Terminator of like I see all and like he
ascertains and grabs things and when I
watch a trailer I go like theme and
comic reference and he's like able to
scan like Modoc so I've never thought of
a trailer the way I think he does I
don't know his brain but like uh I've
I've not done them but I think I would
uh I just Eric's the best at him I think
he can do that those other things too I
think it'd be interesting if you just um
wrote a letter to new rockstars and then
put it on Twitter and asked for him to
be fired oh so you can replace him I see
I assume get him canceled can someone
um should I mail this letter like is it
a handwritten letter I need someone to
clip this out oh yeah
he takes it seriously instead of
realizing that I'm just making
super seriously and Eric movie fighting
over a trailer
um trailer disgusting Ant-Man is a
serious Endeavor all right raccoon
shampoo I think this movie was very
two
not sure it's very good though if that
makes sense I think the same way that
King and uh Ant-Man meeting has
remarkable tension I think that's
it's very palpable attention to that
scene and I think the Segway from The
Flash I think it's a beautiful
transition from the flashbacks to this
where you're like okay this is the pass
and then they transition to the present
with King and he is this presence
I thought it was a great that's like a
great I like that whole 30 minutes with
the probability around but I think
there's that solid like 20 minutes right
yeah is really really good uh yeah and I
think the movie feels actually this is
exactly what I was saying with my non
spoiler review yeah I think it's worth
experiencing there's definitely a reason
to see this movie it's definitely
enjoyable so yeah the movie is very cool
like and I and I was overwhelmed by a
lot of the visuals and I loved the
Freedom Fighters when they were getting
to do the stuff that didn't get
undermined so I think it's all worth
seeing it is cool and a good is a
different thing
is there's just things that could be
richer about it and more you know from
again a cinema filmmaking scripting uh
perspective it could be of a greater uh
caliber or quality but yeah there's
definitely fun and coolness there I need
an impact John sh a leaf what's your
theory for Loki season two thank you for
the Super Chat what's your theory you
gotta have a theory it'll get picked up
for season three you gotta have one
Theory
koi give us one Theory one theory is
that I think we get introduced to a
bunch of Kang variants in much the way
we met a lot of Loki variants but in a
more ominous scary way than than comedic
you know what I would love if they have
like a big finale Showdown with like
Victor Timely
and then out of nowhere a bunch of ant
show
like that's a phase five thing it's just
always act three out of nowhere bunch of
anything walking through like I'm always
following you okay no it's Loki in a
western coat you're gonna smell like
ants we're gonna it's always a puncher
man my theory for Loki season two is
that there will be a jet ski and the key
Quan is gonna be a delight I just I just
want kiquan that's all I care about jet
ski salesman I like he Quant
um was it good is he in it no
I thought of like oh I have to see The
Goonies and then I was like oh but I did
just see Fast and Furious Tokyo Drift
like they're the same thing have you not
seen The Goonies no let's not open that
door right now crazy that's almost
Superman bad I've lost all excitement
and interest in the MCU DC's future
seems more exciting John let me post
this question can I ask you a question
John are you more excited for the future
of DC or the future of the Marvel
Universe which one of these are
currently more excited for okay I want a
straightforward answer I think history
uh DC has more to prove and is in uh
DC has more to prove so the the risk is
higher and the reward could be more uh
gratifying because Marvel right now to
me is like everything is still pretty
good like pretty alright and like
nothing's been terrible so you know it's
mostly just about seeing if they can
bring it back up to great and uh yeah DC
just has like a bunch to prove so cool
quick answer which one uh right now I
think the level of comicy geekiness like
the actual nerd core stuff that's coming
out of DC is pretty exciting and I also
feel like I'm more excited to deal with
a new corner of fandom in in a in an
in-depth way like I feel like I say
anything negative about Marvel even to
compare there's an inherent like what
where is DC I'm like I haven't talked
about it a lot because it's a violence
uh in that fandom that I think is going
to ebb and flow and change so I'm really
excited to show and share my love for DC
so it's personal this is selfish but
there's a lot of characters that I love
that I haven't really gotten to talk
about and share so I'm excited for DC
just because it's a it's a corner of my
heart I haven't gotten to made public oh
man
everyone in the chat
umino has earned that show sure 100 you
better be playing The Lonely Island song
right now hey guys Debbie 900's back at
it yeah for some positivity I love your
reactions to the takamu even though I
don't love those films I know you'd have
to go back but uh just as like the new
frontier and and from 2008 and one room
from 2009 are fantastic well
a big part of their weird journey is
usually me going in there going I think
this is the one yeah
so let's do some research I'll let you
know and just again and lately the past
two have like not been doing is great so
I'm like okay we don't need to mix this
up a little bit because the feedback's
amazing yeah very high but I had a
feeling like a throne of Atlantis might
not be as big of a clicker with this one
uh thank you again for pairing us up for
that
absolutely wonderful no need to thank me
it was all Ebony's idea
Kobe P back again I have a curl
I'm still excited for the future of the
MCU right now hype for guardians galaxy
vol 3 I think it's gonna be amazing my
my expectations cannot be met because
they're so hot James couldn't knows how
to balance the humor with the emotion
people who are like
it's too sci-fi yeah I think we know
someone who's been saying it's like I
think it might be two sci-fi for people
Batman I'm like I don't agree I feel
like Guardians is way more sci-fi
is behaving more weirdly than Quantum
characters are not is a talking raccoon
in a tree I feel like those are the main
characters yeah I think the strength of
Guardians shows how impossibly weird you
can go and still have heart I think I
think a lot of the the people saying
we're nitpicking I can just point at
Guardians and go but look what they did
yeah and it kind of shows that that's
our bar yeah I think there are more
weird images in quantumania than the
movie is actually weird yeah you know
also Guardians 2 is better than the
first fight me I will not fight you
because I can respect people having a
wrong opinion
[Laughter]
you know respect yeah
I'm excited to watch it again no I I
matter it's okay if you like I'm not a
big fan of Guardians too I really don't
um oh my God I'm so excited for this
comment I'll tell you why
um hoshido474
thank you for the Super Chat here uh are
you effort to be honored to be the king
from this movie that's what I'm thinking
they're going to do uh yeah I mean we we
had some comments about that earlier I
completely think that would be an
amazing setup if they did do that and I
think they did enhance it with like him
working with a probability realm version
of himself oh my God that would be an
amazing way to set it up to be the
beyonder
do it
Corey how do you feel you're crashing
yet no but I'm I'm thinking I'm just
trying to respect I'm not trying to
respect your time per one but I I do
think there's a uh a likelihood to get a
different Kang and Secret Wars than the
one we get in Kang Dynasty and I'm
wondering if that's going to be the king
we just met I'm also wondering how much
they're gonna let Jonathan Majors like
play with the Ridiculousness of a bunch
of kangs like are we gonna see uh that I
I think we're gonna see Kang in like
every property going forward except
Guardians be honest but I wonder how
much that's going to change because of
the reception from this film like are
they adding Kang or subtraction King
from Marvel's right now you don't think
they would have like if you don't think
they would have uh Kang and Guardians
three like imagine he's like he's in
Guardians three
he's fighting Adam Warlock
and then a bunch of answers
I wanted every every movie needs a Kang
and saloon interrupted by ants to get us
back to the main okay so here's the
scene you got that like they're walking
up slow right and they're coming up and
you've got Groot and he's doing a
slow-mo walk and then Groot goes I am
man I am ants that's the third act on
your ants I think always always do it I
feel like I feel like The Duffer
Brothers could make a great great oh
that'd be interesting um
I don't know about a movie though
because their expertise is in shows you
know I would have them do is have a uh
side X-Men show like not the main main
oh that would be cool but like an X
Factor or an X not X Force that's a
little too dark but like I would have a
teen drama X team that they handle and
like that slow introduces characters yes
oh they do a great Generation X that
super 90s like Jubilee chamber like have
those characters 90s style Duffer
Brothers Disney plus oh maybe amazing
Finn wolfhard is Wolverine
pretty higher Matarazzo is Beast yeah
uh so do you think would actually not
yeah actually I didn't think about it
you wouldn't be a bad room great that
makes way more sense yeah but he floats
in his red hair yeah but who could Joe
be who could uh Joe carries Booster Gold
already DC's got him yeah he could
Gambit though everyone at once I want
everyone to read I'm so excited for the
Flash
I'm also excited that Warren brothers
hired Andy muschietti to direct their
Attack on Titan live action adaptation
his Direction style perfectly fits the
story like Attack on Titan how would you
define his Direction style oh my god
um put it to the chat amazing
that's that's the thing is he he has
such a status for what just happened
he has such a status and he's getting
these huge projects and no and no shade
whatsoever but I am curious as to what
his style is well
um I think
um because like it just has like a
blockbuster horror style to me it
doesn't really
scream this person's Vision out of the
three of us I'm definitely the biggest
Attack on Titan fan here sure because uh
but uh I I have started
um I've I have I've never read a manga
and I am now on volume two of the attack
on Titan manga because the show's coming
back and I was like rather than
re-watching the show let me just reread
them let me just read the Manga and then
get up to when it before the show
continues like stop right before uh
because it's pretty accurate and dude
it's amazing I love a manga I feel like
I was like let's start previewing other
mangas and I'm like oh my God I think I
might yeah style a little more yeah I'm
a book person yeah I love I'm really I
really love it I feel like does a lot of
really wide sweeping pushes I feel like
musiadi does a lot of uh wider frames
than in the close-up for emotionality
like I think he has a visual style but I
also feel like that that does suit the
little bit I know about this but I also
think that's why I want him for Superman
I think he could do a really cool
Superman yeah it's good point Dan v900
hey can't wait for Justice League Gods
and Monsters next week it might not be
Justice League Gods and Monsters next we
don't know we don't know Greg's gonna
tell us something like commentary wrench
in here it's funny somebody commented
like oh it's so cool you're doing these
in linear order like me and I'm like
hahaha I don't know if that's kind of
whole yes Jovan I did hear me mention on
the on the Mr movies weekly plan my
sister Sunday movies we can plan I got
so excited nerded out so hard over that
he was like so the Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum meeting in his Australian accent
quantumania uh early reactions before
the review embargo lifted have been
great have been like really great but
you know it's not great from everyone
they mentioned my take and I was like oh
God
damn I'm being looked at as the only one
saying something bad and then the
reviews and I was like oh
you were the harbinger I was the you
were the manager
I got a real I don't I I you were the
hair there's time before 2 30. remind me
say Greg tangent get it off your chest
about how people handle early reactions
I got I got some issues we should set up
a thing like like Mr Sunday movies has
the veto we should have like a a tangent
token where once a stream somebody can
take the Tangerine yes I like that the
last dragon lady do you think Victor
timely actually becomes he who remains
no because he who remains made it pretty
clear of like interaction I feel like
that would undercut it too I feel like
you gotta just have it be here who
remains I mean yeah have that be two
distinct characters personally right koi
personally I I think the more kangs is
gonna make the character more
interesting More Kings raccoon shampoo
thank you if the Marvel Awards awards
exist then I think Kang should win worse
instrument wow I hope he gets a better
disposal Army for Avengers it was real
uh undermining when you do think like
I've built this Army to take to conquer
I'm like
yeah I was like you've clearly focused
on quantity over the quality of your
product sir these things don't aren't
effective at all fair enough also are
they organic because the one dude reads
their mind yeah and then like he talks
like I I was gonna stop you yeah yeah
like there's no room I'll die first damn
which funny but did he burst them like
in that case he birthed them
that's what Janet didn't she uh
thousands of thousands of Kang babies
things work differently than Quantum
Roman Aaron kalachi thank you I've had
the opinion since the Loki that will the
Loki that will see all the road lead to
King think we'll see him in many movies
coming up first of many being Miss
Marvel and credits to grasp him he is
always involved I think you get too much
a king it can be a little undermined I
mean like always thinking that there's
gonna be a lot of King but I think he
got a space everything you really got to
space it out there's too much King I
think it becomes less exciting well I
think it'd be cool if they introduce
certain kangs that aren't as big bad
yeah so you have contrast yeah what do
you think I'd like to see a the Marvels
can be a like regular guy even like you
could just have someone Jonathan Majors
could show up like it's interesting to
have levels of threat but they have the
conundrum of like we know where this guy
might go exactly and that would I add a
little bit more than just like it's the
biggest Kang ever oh no it's not like
I'd like to just have a lower level yeah
just have like a regular guy who doesn't
have time travel but still have a bunch
of answers
always have a bunch of ants show up in
the space that's all I want I want to
leverage
any MCU movie that can trigger the ants
to show up and then they just cut to
that trailer that I love so much I want
them to go back and CG the ants into the
end of end game yeah retroactively they
just they're on your left as well I
don't rock we got I think we got two in
here as some as the same one out of two
I don't see the second part it's gonna
be weird yeah don't worry
MCU is missing rdj's Tony Stark he's so
great to Anchor the infinity Saga
interacted with multiple Heroes
enhancing dim I thought after end game
strange Thor would be that anchor but
Marvel failed to do that uh yeah I mean
I guess maybe the sense of unity is not
really so much explaining how everything
connects but having a couple of defined
leaders you know because there's no real
there's no Avengers right now though
that's the thing is there's no there's
no actual Avengers yeah and there's yeah
there's not any like central figure I do
think that's an issue is that like
everyone wants to have a hub you're
growing and coming back to and growing
coming back to in phase one through
three was like we leave The Avengers to
go back to the Avengers The Avengers
break up they come back together and I
do think that it's not necessarily I
mean obviously Tony Stark and Steve
Rogers and Thor all huge but I also
think it's the sense of that Unity that
maybe Shang Chi is going to be or maybe
you know Wong could have been there
should be uh more of a figure I agree
yeah
Perhaps Perhaps you're all wrong
um I felt like they were setting up
Doctor Strange personally and that it
just didn't like yeah like I really
thought he was the new Tony for them but
Tony Stark
I'm gonna put a suit of armor around the
quantum realm new stores I don't mean to
sound dark
but I wanted to see Ant-Man lose to
someone I expected someone to get killed
off and I hate they got rid of Modoc so
quick
Modoc I think you can easily variant
back into the fold I think it would have
been called the CM and get killed off
and it would have yeah I would have
given him that Arc that we John and I
were talking about earlier but at the
same time you know maybe they'll kill
him off at the beginning of King Dynasty
they'll locium you know you know what I
mean it's right at the top just kill him
off right at the top him and wasp I
don't begrudge them not losing someone
but I feel like yeah it would have been
a very interesting thing to do the
opening of King Dynasty is wasp walking
into a CVS going fine I'm gonna get the
shot
I'm gonna get it
and then King shows up and I wonder how
much that I wonder how much that
affected her care like they didn't pull
Bill Murray out because he's become
problematic but he's also playing the
exact person he is problematic for being
yeah so it's people were okay with that
Evangeline lily leaves in science in
this world that's why she's acting
Peyton Reed said
Peyton Reed said it was that didn't
matter they don't care about that they
said they all were they didn't wear
masks
I mean what does it all mean for Scar's
hairline
who who needs oh scar my God yeah
there's so much stuff I forgot all about
that those all mean for scars it will
keep receding we just had that show and
like we're already so like there's so
much going like I want Scar's hairline
to to keep encroaching on his voice say
what you will about the She-Hulk finale
I think it's a great representation of
some of the chaos that is the Marvel
setup Pantheon at the moment of like
yeah no it's kind of all over the place
right now some of it's great so but I
don't really know exactly where it's
going but something but somehow King
unites it all that's a great example of
me being like I thought this was going
to land in Phase five and six and then
being like well we can get rid of three
of the shows because it doesn't really
I'm like if it was so cohesive that
wouldn't be as easy to shoot yeah like
that that's why I'm worried for the
first time because if we're only getting
secret Invasion and uh what's the other
one this year Loki Loki this year and
they're able to move three of their five
shows to another year then how does that
impact everything is it a domino effect
they're recording for or is it not as
cohesive don't forget about the the rest
Resurrection though
um
yeah yeah that's going to connect too so
this is an Avenger Jonathan who's going
to play Jesus Jesus was a king variant I
would love he comes out he moves the
Rock and he's like hey Jesus
if you don't clean up after the Last
Supper
Shield vids I just thought about what
who's that Hollywood Reporter said the
war between the Kings is the threat
there's we are so focused on King versus
US May the problem will come when he
fights himself and causes incursions and
that's why I think you should if there's
a combination of well who wrote that
book Justin Thoreau Jackson Jackson
Justin Bieber
like I don't I don't buy a lot of comics
I mean I'll I have the Marvel unlimited
app and I got an iPad and I read a lot
from there and it's actually a really
great way to do because it like focuses
on one section because you I can have a
bit of a visuals over stimulation with a
full page frames frames
like how it just focuses in and that's
how I've been reading Attack on Titan
attack and also if you've never read
Comics it's really nice to not get
overwhelmed by the medium if you've
never touched it it guides you through
the page so Marvel unlimited highly
recommend and yeah Jackson lansing's
Kang 2021 yeah great jumping on point
Justin Thoreau Justin throw dude
um but yeah I would like that and we got
the second part of your question here on
Rock we forget that we've seen Tony
every year from 2015 to 2021 and the new
movies doesn't make us care about
journey of protagonists it makes me fear
if MCU would be reactionary bringing
Tony bring back Tony and Cat That's My
worry you think they'll bring it back I
think Downey has had a few years off to
like you know down eat up I hope but
he's had a flourishing career since then
don't know it's not that I think he just
doesn't have the scale of Tony's like
when he's when he's playing Tony Stark
he gets to be Tony Stark yeah
Oppenheimer he's playing you know a
scientist and and he's had great things
happen Oppenheimer yeah he's in the
trailer oh cool
but I think that uh that there's a
there's a wonderful like
hero fulfillment being Tony Stark so I
get that I worry that both he and Chris
will come back and it'll undermine phase
three no no no I think they should bring
back Chris and Captain America New World
Order
uh Sam Wilson just never gets to let's
say at the very end Sam Wilson's
struggling and then Steve Rogers on the
back of a bunch of ants yeah that would
be great this is a subplot of of Sam
always calling Steve being like what do
I do man instead of nomad he is white
savior no I think I think Sam Wilson
might oh actually you know that that's
what they should do they should focus on
him being the anchor maybe no new world
order will help us like anchor around
Sam because he's from the original guard
he he is going to be like the leader of
the Avengers like they're nice to to
have something unite around yeah if they
bring back Tony I want it to be Sinister
I wanted to fake you out into being like
oh good dad's oh no he's not you know
yeah I would rather that I like that too
let him do the the heel turn version so
it's interesting when they bring back
old man Stark in the in the Brian
Michael Benders John Mayer Jr draw on
Avengers stuff there is a there's a
nefariousness to him that'd be fun I
love that secret Wars now has the SW
moniker because because the order of
events in my Minds whenever I see SW
goes sex work Star Wars and now
man
it's not as bad as Ryan said earlier
first post-credits scene just felt weird
to me
yeah it's a little kooky yeah yeah I
know it's a little wacky we have
nitpicked the [__] out of that
post-credit scene already it's the theme
of the day I am excited to do my live
show with campia and harloff tomorrow
when I've already reached the point
where I'm sick of talking about this
movie and now I'll do it in front of a
live audience
I am ready to put this to rest guys
um
that could be the the flavor you bring
the show probably needs that I'll be
like sure guys whatever you think
assuming all the attitude yeah whatever
you need to be the Wild Card Joshua Nova
Novoa do you think space in the movies
TV show out will significantly increase
the riding the infinity Saga was like 10
years but the Saga is ending in like two
it does it does
um it would it would help to space it
out I do think it is especially because
you if not every project is going to
have a long lasting impression or feel
great like truly great then it does
start to feel like you're getting over
saturated I did not have that concern
until a little while in defense I was
like I don't feel like they're over
saturated there's a big variety of them
and then they now get out of the park a
lot of time and I to me I do think they
should spread this out a little bit I
think they are we're hitting three
movies two shows this year that's like
half the concept we got last year right
yes yes it is it is less so that's yeah
I think they're looking at that yes yes
it is and I have a lot of Hope for the
marbles and I and I hope that that maybe
in this in moving some of these things
out of the oh cool yeah sure yeah why
not you know what like I understand my
feelings about that movie and having
thumbed through the uh God butcher comic
I'm like yes I can see that this would
have been a very different and probably
much more agreeable and badass movie but
I still love a lot of what's in there
um but I I don't think that it's
actually bad that they're moving certain
things out out of the timeline because I
think some things should be contained
and some things should be very serial
and I think part of the No Man's Land of
phase four has been that they've been
kind of in the middle on all that yeah
it's like a little connectivity kind of
but not as much as anyone seems to
expect and everything's kind of Serial
but not so just true I feel like they're
both trying to appeal to the people that
make tick tocks analyzing every single
Easter egg wait and the mainstream
audience um but Strife I do I have a
question from Strife here I say I did
that natural
um
uh yo so uh he would pay you to explain
the entire MCU oh the entire MCU yeah uh
well I would pay to have Luis do that
from and I think that was the thing they
could have done to start phase five but
instead you should do a video that gets
updated every phase where it is a
comprehensive explanation of the phase
up until now and then you just re-upload
that video the next time but with it
with an addendum that ever grows
honestly like with the MCU shows being
so dense and there being so many of them
not quite tying in it would have been
really interesting to see Louise talk
about the ncu shows to Paul Rudd like
you were gone five years serious what
happened now there's a lady Hulk and
there's like this and there's so much
fun and instead I will I will accept
your Canadian dollars to do the same
yeah no it's crazy but Kevin black has a
question he says uh Hey guys sorry it
was a disappointment I would recommend
having watched on Edibles felt 10 times
weirder and watching three times
about 10 times weird times watch it on
Edibles
um I can't watch a movie in the theaters
on Edibles or even like with one hit I I
can't you get to like I I didn't feed
her I I my mind cannot process it it's
too it's too much for me to handle too
much stimulation yeah like some people
are like you should smoke and read
comics and I'm like yeah it's really
hard for me to do that it's epic than a
movie I have a hard time watching a
movie in the theaters and I I just can't
for some reason my brain I already have
a fast-moving brain and and my mouth
cannot keep up with my brain like I
cannot spit out as like I can't do what
koi does where it's like your mouth your
mouth and brain seem to be like like the
second computer and my mind's moving too
fast that I can't sometimes I can't
articulate it I I struggle with that at
times and I think that the way to watch
this movie would actually be on uh well
what did I say so you don't get in
trouble on YouTube the thing that in
forms the the zombies in Last of Us I
would last of us this experience uh
those that edible experience would be
fun I could watch stuff at home this
will be great at home but I can't do
theaters is too big yeah and there's
speaking main problem if it's too big
for me I just can't handle it sip that
lean the next time Evan Fowler little
scissor like there are some movies like
I would love to do a reaction to dread
because I saw that on an edible and I
can't tell you a thing that happened
no idea what happened in that movie
um and uh there's other movies like that
too
I don't know what happened because it's
not an edible cocaine it's gonna be a
time Damon from Tex as John likes to say
thank you for the moment of silence
Career Development thank you buddy could
you shout out my wife uh Taiko YTD tell
her happy Valentine's Day for me Christy
Waits Happy Valentine's Day
my God you got a great great hubby here
and he's lucky to have someone as fine
and understanding as you plus you guys
goodness is so secure being the career
he's Career Development that's amazing
you gotta have that I found the right
guy yeah what big clarky has to say I
assume they now have a portal to come to
the quantum realm anytime they want I
mean it would seem that way also if they
are quantum sized then what size are
their atoms koi you got 10 seconds
theoretically everything would get
denser as the scale shrinks because
they're able to use that density to get
violent because they're able to change
that in real time with inertia so
conceptually their atoms would be
proportional to their size but still
that much smaller oh you did it thank
you big clarky conceptually oh my God
you have to wear the suit so true but
Daniel Jones has a question he says Hey
guys big fan of the channel did you all
discuss if Scott effed up I have a
theory that this King wasn't the True
Villain just as approached about it was
a more violent version of He Who remains
I think there's an interesting idea that
it's like each Kang we meet in this tan
the the better argument for this isn't
the prime Kang we'll see him down the
line is that yeah like maybe this one
was telling the truth in that you're not
gonna like what comes instead of me and
and if you think I'm bad that's even
worse and so maybe it is like yeah this
guy's not a good guy but at the same
time maybe he's not the worst guy and
maybe true we should have listened sure
and that ties into that last ominous bit
of Scott walking I like that oh my God
yeah absolutely a hundred percent same
page yes and all the way nickel wrath
just left the cinema now Michael wrath
dude I really like it better than most
of the films of phase four I mean do you
um is is there a
John uh what's the thing you like least
in phase four
uh
oh I set it up nicely for you probably
Hawkeye do you like this more than
Hawkeye
uh sure yes we got there koi I like it
like more than Kate bishop and uh you
know movie or all all uh I think my
lowest is what if and I like this more
than what if hell yeah that's great to
hear my lowest was uh Shang Chi and I
like this more than Sean Black Panther
wakanda forever is my lowest I hated no
way home he told me
um yeah I was too woke for me
too many women they killed why they make
Aunt May Uncle Ben come on it's right
there come on agenda thanks for the
Super Chat here Jay hey you guys listen
we gotta understand this was just an
exiled King in the quantum realm without
the right things he needed he can only
do so much being smart I thought he was
fierce with a weakness of ants uh yeah
well you know I still feel like he was
down there for a while and he had enough
technology to conquer the quantum realm
I think that he still could have been
more prepared and showed more of a
ruthlessness and built some better
things to combat people and perhaps the
movie would have just worked a little
bit better for me if displayed some of
his excellent strategy sure during the
battle because that's a big part of Kang
strategist Navigator The Art of War
I saw very little strategy after a point
and those first two acts no he turned
into fire every day
well I mean it is his chance to get out
I don't know we didn't we don't need to
talk about it I know but he still could
use strategy yeah sure he could have
well John became a massive Marvel shell
after a third Beauty I just had a way
it's it like the movie improved a little
bit on
technical rating but the experience
improved to like an eight or so like I
actually had fun the third time and and
even if I was like logically I don't
love this choice but The overarching
Whimsy and silliness brought everything
together in a way that was really fun to
experience especially with a crowd who
again wasn't like oh yeah but was into
it so I would love to be a kid watch
this movie enjoyable experience I think
there's a big difference between I would
love to be a kid and watch this movie
and this is for kids and also guys they
make these movies for kids because
plenty of kids movies are made for kids
and adults plenty of things are
enjoyable as a kid and adult and I think
you shouldn't lower your bar for the
sake of it being enjoyable for all ages
whoa do you guys hear that there's a
moment of silence here from kdr401
thanks buddy raccoon shampoo thanks
again dude
with how fast Greg figured out the dog
situation a lot of credit goes to the
misses as well maybe James Gunn should
cast Greg is the DCU flash I would love
to be him but I would only Channel Ezra
Miller the entire time I have no other
brain for myself sure sure what's going
on John nothing it's very intense
focused I have no idea what just
happened there I'm just reading some
options Vasquez Joseph
thank you for the Super Chat loved
y'all's content but do you think the
movie would have been more impactful or
better if Scott had sacrificed himself a
hundred thousand percent yes so that
hoping Cassie could make it back a
hundred thousand percent yes I even had
a little bit of call it nitpicking
um I just think that if Kane really
wanted out he wouldn't have wasted his
time fighting Ant-Man I think he would
have got it out
I was like the door's right there this
guy's clearly down you can just run just
get over there yeah
I think he could have gotten out or if
he had lost something like in other
trilogies yeah I mean this movie is full
of signposts of like oh there's an
opportunity for something rich There's
an opportunity for something rich
There's an opportunity for something
rich and they don't take a lot of them I
wouldn't have been as angry at the top
of this conversation in live chat if I
didn't have hope for what it could have
been and therefore these things are
things that I noticed and that was the
problem yeah the the thing the the some
of the most contentious aspects of the
movie are just potential not realized or
not taken on the opportunity I'm all the
Ant-Man Scots in that scene going like
the potentials yeah I just see all the
potentials and right now I'm
Baskin-Robbins why am I here
yeah do you have ice cream I love do you
have ice cream guy though that was
always good well I gotta say though man
but like Bryce burris's comment here
which I really appreciate he enjoyed the
hell out of the movie good he didn't go
into it watching any videos or clips of
it only the two main trailers it's a lot
of that's mainly the movie
because to edit the review for because
the thing about our the review I did
with John is we were all over the place
so it took me a long time to edit it it
was almost 40 minutes of footage and
then I had so to make it easier to find
my inserts I had to do a cut of the
footage from the trailers and put it in
Timeline order of the movie to make it
easier to find your footage and I was
like oh most of the movies in here
which is an odd phenomenon where on the
heels of the previous phase where
they're like we're only showing you act
one but I'm glad you I'm glad you really
liked it though I mean yeah they sort of
show you him fighting they literally
have these big line of like we just both
have to lose in the trailer it's like
that's the that's the end that's like 10
seconds later a king loses Caleb Wong
Caleb I just love the shot when the
helmet goes down in the trailer of
ant-man's element and you're like oh my
God he's gonna die like it's such a
trailer shot because of like I know it's
gonna be in the movie but it's not going
to be this town and sure enough I am
we're safe yeah Caleb Wong hey Caleb
guess what he says I was just waiting
for Dom threader to come in and save
Scott with his charger and beat up King
I know a family that would have been
cool in one universe that happened it's
true there is a there isn't all Universe
I think Jonathan major is actually a
great villain for a fast oh I would love
that he'd be a great Bond villain too
I'd see him like I only want to see him
play villains never a hero he's an
interesting person of ocean Dom Toretto
he was released
devotion surprised me because I think of
him very like as a darker character but
in devotion he had to play someone that
was like stoic because of societal
expectations but still heroic and it
didn't undermine his gravitas he's able
to be like pensive in a very morose and
sad way and then the moments of heroism
are really profound because he never
gets to be like the weight's always on
her shoulders in that movie he's so good
in devotion which is so true I mean
Lovecraft country as well wait a minute
wait a minute
a Moment of Silence from M severe thank
you so much are you the one with the
Toyota Celica
[Laughter]
hey guys any beer you want as long as
it's a Corona
he he and Jenny had Coronas when they
fixed the engine it had a lot of things
um blade's not gonna suck they only got
to reshoot and rewrite the whole thing I
think it's gonna be great because they
took the time to do that I was supposed
to come out it literally the reason
there's a November date for Captain
Marvel to take is because that was where
blade was supposed to land exactly
that's how late this movie is I think
they pushed it for all the right reasons
and they're shooting in like a few weeks
now yeah it's me R-rated yeah no May
yeah no it's going to be harder hard R
NC-17 I think Deadpool beat up battle
Angel actually I think the 48 Ant-Man
might get us blade radar I'm sorry for
saying all this aegon zero one two I
don't know if you watched Jaden
previewed they said that phase four
shouldn't have been named phase four but
as an interlude stage interesting should
have been them don't call it phase four
why this should have been the proper
starting to face for it I mean thoughts
uh phase one is disparate the only
difference is that you have a definitive
Avengers to Market
yeah I think that the way that 3x
structures in film work is the way that
3x structures in the MCU works so you
still need the phase one which is the
phase four
I know there's just lots of debating and
there's lots of you know stuff like that
appropriate to a First Act of something
they should have called it phase woke am
I right men right yeah there are almost
as many women as men in it I hate that I
hate that job is just supposed to birth
us Jones
thanks PJ
I like this movie but I have liked
majority of phase four and now this
unlike most people hey question
thanks for being here do you guys think
if Gardens gal 33 gets negative views I
don't think it will that people will
give up on the MCU there's no giving up
on the MCU because the only thing that
gets negative reviews are the Council of
critics that decide to assemble together
and vote unanimously on what the
percentage scores like this one and then
the audience goes Rebel black or tomato
will it be yeah it's actually just uh
yeah I think it's just one guy I think
Guardians three is is such a acceptable
because people know no one really goes
like the Peyton like there's a very few
films like Thor 11 Thunder gets a lot of
crap from taika ytt not necessarily
Marvel like Marvel definitely but a lot
of the conversation goes to Taiko ytd's
film this will go more to James Gunn's
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 whereas like
Ammon in the WASP quantumanium you got
some people who acknowledge it's Peyton
reads movie it really feels like another
Marvel film you know it feels like
Marvel direction also look at phase four
action actually like it got a Shang Chi
it got us no way home it got us wakanda
forever even if you I mean one division
yeah there's so much goodness in it so I
feel like people are just pointing out
the negative because there is there if
there's 10 properties and three are bad
then that's still a better ratio than
most franchises and there isn't that
many bad compared to many are good I I
think it's a very interesting thing that
we're like so quick to judge
they've given us way more good than that
that's what I'm saying
I agree no I totally agree and I feel
like when things are just kind of all
right at people
are more upset by it that's not true you
saw three times Adam Ramirez how is
Sylvie gonna feel all those chickens
huh
what happened just now eat all those
chickens Sylvie what what's happening
what about chickens is she supposed to
be is this like are they gonna make love
or something that is that a stroke I
don't know what's going on what do
chickens means have something to do with
the McDonald's thing Sylvie from she
getting nuggets I don't understand these
words don't make sense in this order to
be Adam Ramirez if you're still in the
chat clarify help me out we would like
to love to answer your question I love
how confused I am avron I need to spin
off with the outcast characters oh my
God I would love that I would love for
them to do a Daryl show their role where
he hangs out with the outcast characters
I still want to pet Avengers man we've
got enough there's enough pets it's true
we can make a pet Avengers I think they
should do it without dialogue too
yeah whole episode yeah do it like
Homeward Bound it'll be like what the
hell's going on he's a dog and flirting
cat they should just have a lot of
scenes where they like full on scenes
that are like 10 minutes long that are
dialogue driven but they don't give us
subtitles so it's just like a dog
barking in a cat meowing it's high art
like I don't know what's happening
that's what I mean it's profound but I'm
glad they dedicated the time crocodile
Loki walks by this little hat yeah I
don't care
sending extra love before I head out
because this was the best part of my
weekend really
I always respect the thoughtfulness of
your reviews
the weekend's just begun you got this
you got a whole Saturday night Sunday to
go that's so sweet of you thank you so
much appreciate it Heather oh my god
dude Disney does pay really well I love
how people were like all from those paid
reviewers I've never heard of someone
Disney paved for viewers to give it bad
reviews that's that would be awesome if
they would pay thank you heather
stranger I would gladly accept pay
pay me and I will recommend your movie
I'll change my opinion Disney delete all
these videos I will delete them all if
you pay me enough to supplement the loss
sure it does come on Disney
oh that would be such a good video to
monetize if I like expose Disney for
trying to pay me yeah oh my God how
great of a video
I can make more money by exposing you
double this money yes create fake news
aegon zero one two would it have been
better if someone died who well dude no
King died it was great it was yeah it
totally worked it worked I think I think
did die I fell man that was great he
died in Avenger he died in Avenger all
right I think we're at the end here let
me just do a quick refresh everyone
holds your horses everyone hold your
horses steady steady keep cool that's
how I have to talk to John campio
tomorrow
steady
calm down Johnny
you're gonna do the Chris Pratt hand
with John Campion hey and harloff though
he's gotta you gotta keep him please
please
here's a carrot
I'm gonna bring carrots on stage I'm
very excited for this chaos
thank you so much here I think
quantumania was meh was just setting me
in my review I can't visit the he was
threatening because of John Madge only
Quantum realm is boring characters
boring story boring boring is a worse
review for a movie than bad just mundane
monotonous sad it but whatever
I never found it boring I never found it
boring I was born I thought there were
certain choices that were very stock but
uh but yeah I get what you mean though
like something Matt is worse than bad
you're not done
I just felt like Ant-Man was sideline
for the quantum realm yes it's called
quantumania it's also called Ant-Man and
the WASP didn't feel like there was
there were more
you know I'm Italian so I feel like I
could say the racial slur but that
begins with the w Ant-Man on the whop
I'm always tempted to say it yeah sure
didn't feel like they were important at
all flagged on Twitch the other day for
saying the Irish word that rhymes with
Rick and I was shocked like I actually
got oh really yeah damn I thought it was
mine I thought I could now which one of
those two swords is more offensive I
didn't feel like they were important all
and I just feel like how unless useless
this movie actually felt like Loki my
favorite TV show of all time alongside
like two other my favorite team shooting
on Marvel TVs TV show so Loki 2 doesn't
live up I'll smack Marvel out of my life
goodbye disappointment now I can live
without constant fear of failing he's
got fairies
that is a life-changing it sounds like
this movie was a great experience for
you overall then if you can alleviate
that fear of failure my God that's
profound that's like therapy John
struggles with that on a minute to
minute basis I do don't even
it will be a chaotic experience and it
sounds like to me it was a worthwhile
experience to get rid of that emotion
for you though
hey Diego Alaska thank you for the
Streamline I've been watching since I
was 1-1 now 20. and while we've come a
long way since tasm II also hope this
ages well but I really believe the next
Superman movie could be one of the best
super Netflix ever Superman downright is
powerful oh my God yes have you guys
seen Coy's video on DC views versus the
snyderverse where he flat out says Zack
Snyder's movies are terrible and the fan
base is the worst thing in the world
that is what I said never watch Zack
Snyder's Justice League oh I said it and
I was right there he was looking at the
video going pants
yeah yeah just like watched it burn up
in his hand tackling maniacally yeah and
then we get this great opacity yeah
Factory blending you into the Inglorious
Bastards and certainly kills all the
Nazis yeah people love the video I think
that Superman has to be a force of of
Hope and light and I think that the
world needs that more than ever so the
bar is high in this film No it should be
Henry Cavill yeah playing Superman I
would love to see under cabin places
destroy some buildings yes Lana Pico the
super chats have closed you might be
able to leave a sticker not a Pico yeah
yeah she's great she's awesome terrific
John subscribes for only fans number one
customers are every only fans everyone
send me send me your [__] and I'll
subscribe to you no no no it's okay I
made it right
Talon is only fans I don't think so
well I would feel I would feel strange
maybe you should have a professional
maybe you shouldn't have watched Ant-Man
for a third time and instead gone with
the people
I went to be with the people Clinton
watts and then Corey released a bunch of
ants and Zack Snyder's heads
a rebel Moon just has a bunch of ants
living underneath it now why there's
like Hoya again I like ants let me make
sure this is the last of everything
including
it is the last of that one everyone
everyone cool your jets
oh no we did miss
one Super Chat
one super look at this tree from chatty
oh
oh she made it herself oh tree sticker
thank you loving it so sweet so sweet
and uh last one from the stream Labs
White Hawk 842 why talk the best color
I'm split on this movie I want to like
this movie but it feels like critics
make it feel like it's wrong to enjoy
something that others dislike no
riddicks make you feel that no critics
critics make you feel that way critics
speaking superbs
not fandom critics critics can speak
definitively in a way that makes you
feel like your opinion might be invalid
by it yeah I don't that's that's not
good I think it's really weird that we
look at Rotten Tomatoes as like do I see
this movie or not I think you should
look at a movie and go I should do this
movie or not like it doesn't make any
sense to let critics affect your
experience in general like we we should
be the thing you refer to after you see
the movie and I don't even consider
myself a critic but like Greg said we do
critique on the internet and things are
monetized so like there's an element to
that but it shouldn't be the deciding
factor for you and no one should control
your experience of something if you
enjoy something and other people don't
you're in the benefit you had two hours
of better life than I did if I didn't
enjoy it for two hours and you did for
two hours I'm happier for your
experience than mine so don't let anyone
inform anything you do except you well
and a Critic doesn't just speak within
us such an authority do they
I also don't know any critic that I
listen to I I think you can re
especially if you're reading I think you
can read a Critic and feel like yeah
this is a definitive statement on this
movie this is how it is and and granted
it's up to you to be like no it's still
just their opinion and in writing
classes they tell you don't say in my
opinion just say what it is yeah and so
I I do feel like the point is a Critic
they do yeah sometimes not it's not
Universal and obviously people break
from that but yes it's a it's a
formality that like in a newspaper
review you might see or something like
that but I think the the thing to
remember is that if you are a person who
really loves movies who has seen a lot
of movies who cares in any way about
Cinema and filmmaking in an invested way
congratulations you are at at the rung
of of you're pretty much like all the
other critic critics are just people
who've seen a lot of movies care about
movies and have some vague knowledge of
how they're made and are giving their
opinions based off of that so really the
way critics get lumped into this
category of being like a whole other
kind of person with a whole other
it doesn't really uh
oh Jaws uh yeah I don't understand the
separation Humanities like it's a very
odd thing that's happened in the last 10
years with the online culture being what
it is it's I feel like fandom is so much
more aggressive fandom is full of
critics fandom is like if if you if you
like something that a big part of fandom
doesn't like they
they harass you threats and I'm not a
paid critic I get death I harass you
it's insane like the top comment on our
Ant-Man video is like
you guys recommended Thor 11 thunder so
I'm like God damn this [__] haunts me
every discussion of a movie door love
and thunder is the only one that haunts
me I don't I really don't mind admitting
to a movie that I like if others don't I
don't mind liking I don't mind not
liking a movie either
um like I really was under the
impression Quantum made it's like
everyone's gonna love this and I'm gonna
be the only one that is I was really
under that impression such a good time
with love and better with you when we
didn't see it but yeah there's a reason
I don't really care for premieres
anymore but like yeah
but no they're alone with thunder I'm
like no matter how many times I've said
it like it only bothers me on that one
because I'm like I've said it 500 times
second viewing it did not it really
didn't work for me that much like the
second review and it really did it went
down a lot for me but it was still
haunted by that and people are still
saying it I've seen it I've seen real
rejects mentioned on Marvel Studios
Reddit for for liking for being like you
can't listen to them
that bothers me because I feel like hey
when it comes to criticism in general
but I would say especially for movies
like these it should always be fun and a
joy to talk about them and if it's
getting angsty something is going wrong
but also I I just feel like
people want in a weird way people don't
like the critical hive mind and yet also
still want there to be one accepted take
on a movie so people go yeah you like
blood and thunder so I can't trust you
when it's like everybody has one or two
movies that they kind of disagree with
everybody else on or that Charmed them
and you go yeah I get why this doesn't
work for people as much as I am the most
positive on Thor 11 thunder in this room
and and enjoy a lot of immediate things
about that movie I mean sure there are
flaws with it there are things that
could be better easily I happen to like
it and I don't feel like that should
discredit me that should be another
reason just to form your own opinion
also like there's everyone's experience
going into the movies
if you can articulate why you like
something in a way that makes sense I
feel like you shouldn't be subject I
want to use DC because it's it's not the
MCU but like DC like BBS to me those
aren't the characters Batman versus
Superman but I got more out of Shazam
because I think adoption is really
important and I think family is really
important I think talking about you're
not blood family is really important but
if someone lived their whole life I'm
34. so in 34 years that's something that
shaped me is how important I think
adoption is how important I think uh
family is and all those things but if
you don't share that you might get more
out of BBS than uh than Shazam but that
doesn't mean Shazam is better than BBS
or BBS is better than Shazam it just
means that what we go into that movie
for is different so you can't listen to
one person that had didn't have your
life experience it's not logical so much
less listening to critics as some sort
of like above-board Kang Council it
makes no sense most critics I know
aren't just people that love movies and
a lot of them like that's their only
thing and that also makes them
differently cynical or differently
joyous it just makes them extreme and
they have to write in black and white so
it's very silly to judge anything based
on that and everything we said today was
our opinion our experience that you
happen to want to see if you were here
most of you at the beginning of the chat
was its own thing but most most of you
are here for the right reason and that's
your choice so see what you want enjoy
what you want don't ever apologize for
your opinion of joy
on that note
John loves the word love and thunder I
like it a lot it'll haunt us I have love
for that movie
no I do like it a lot so guys listen
um no I still give Thor 11th under like
a six out of ten it just makes the mark
for me yeah anyway guys listen everyone
I want everyone to follow koi on his
YouTube channel he's doing videos and
it's doing good it's doing great I want
everyone to follow John at the Greg Alba
and
Dad John Humphrey and at real Rejects
and also um I want everyone here to know
I appreciate you being here everyone has
been very kind
well not everyone but you know what I
mean
um and this was a a good time plenty of
alcohol required everyone remember drunk
streams those are fun
yeah yeah yeah all the streams are fun
streams were pretty wild you should do
or drunk Super Bowl day I remember that
one day we were doing like shots between
every every trailer we should drink
absent to watch Green Lantern together I
want to say to uh I love that koi is 34.
uh does anyone have medicine for koi
I Got Ants so we we gotta we gotta end
this now I gotta go do some editing and
whatnot but thank you for being here
thank you everyone a contributor super
chats and streamlabs your support means
a lot with you it all goes to fun koi's
retirement so as a senior citizen you
can finally quit Walkers aren't cheap
and uh Christine thanks for being here
make sure everyone's going to show up
tomorrow at the event
um hopefully I have some sleep tonight
and I want you to know he's gonna bring
his designation loves you all yeah bye
Jenny Bye Matt bye Bing Bong boy bye
Liam buy Alan Smithy
it should be thanks John Coy and Greg No
it should be thanks Greg Coyne John No
it should be thanks
koi John it's a smooth friend it should
be thanks ants all right guys listen I'm
gonna I'm gonna call it a day now I
believe uh and I've saved enough animals
Ayahuasca streams I like ants I like to
see you guys soon John
how do I end the stream
hit the big red button that says end and
it will end the entire stream we'll
close the stream down and then you'll
stop uh on the other software well in
tandem see you guys later peeps
ants I like ants I like ants like ants
do I hit this button